If you're a conference organizer, do you want to pitch that, though? Because if I'm a employer... Oh, for sure. Doesn't mean you're going to switch companies? So that's the worry, I think, is that conference organizer doesn't want to say that because it sounds like, oh, we're going to send you to a conference and then in a year you're not going to be at our company anymore. No, they absolutely want to say that, I think.
如果你是会议组织者，你会想以此作为宣传卖点吗？因为如果我是雇主……哦，当然会。这并不意味着你一定会跳槽，对吧？所以我认为大家担心的是，会议组织者不想这么说，因为听起来就像是：“哦，我们把你送到会议上，结果一年后你就不在我们公司工作了。”不，我认为他们绝对想这么说。
All right, I'm a conference organizer. Sell me on why this should be the tagline. Yeah, a lot of it came out of me doing code reviews, my team. helping folks on my team, looking at the kind of code that we write and trying to raise the level of abstraction there. So, you know, working down at the embedded layer, tons of things like bit twiddling, you know, shifting things into the right place, so they'll be in the right field of the register, lots of things like that, that just, sure, you can, you can do it, but we haven't really come a long way in that area above what see could do in 1972. so the thing.
好吧，假设我是会议组织者。请说服我为什么这应该成为宣传标语。嗯，这很大程度上源于我为团队做代码审查，帮助团队成员，审视我们编写的代码，并试图提高其中的抽象水平。所以，你知道，在嵌入式底层工作时，会有大量位操作，比如移位，把数据移到寄存器的正确位置，诸如此类的事情。当然，你确实可以这样做，但在这一领域，我们并没有比 1972 年 C 语言能做的事情进步多少。所以就是这样。
Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 26, recorded on December 22nd, 2025. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Ben, we record our holiday special number five. In this episode, we chat about CPPCon, NDC Toronto, C++ now, teletext, bamboozle, and more. Anyways, like I said earlier, we put the cart in front of the horse. This is technically our happy holidays, you know, Christmas episode. Last episode of the year, this will drop on December 26th Boxing Day for some folks in the world. I assume not every country has Boxing Day.
欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 26 期，录制于 2025 年 12 月 22 日。我是 Connor，今天我和联合主持人 Ben 一起录制我们的第五期节日特辑。在这一期中，我们聊了 CPPCon、NDC 多伦多、C++ Now、图文电视、恶作剧等等。总之，就像我之前说的，我们有点本末倒置了。这严格来说是我们的节日快乐，也就是圣诞节特辑。这是今年的最后一期，将于 12 月 26 日节礼日（Boxing Day）发布，这对世界上的一些人来说是节礼日。我猜并非每个国家都有节礼日。
Does Canada have Boxing Day as well? We definitely have Boxing Day, yes. I don't typically, and for those that are not familiar with Boxing Day, it is, I have no idea why it's called Boxing Day, but it is the day after Christmas where there are massive sales across, I don't know, corporations and businesses, so you can go and get heavily discounted items. And I rarely ever go to stores on Boxing Day because it is similar to Black Friday and it's just pandemonium. Yeah, I would have to say Boxing Day is. more normally associated in the UK with just eating leftovers. Many families go out for a walk on boxing day to try and get over the huge amount of food intake. Yeah.
加拿大也有节礼日吗？我们确实有节礼日，是的。我通常……对于那些不熟悉节礼日的人来说，我完全不知道它为什么叫节礼日，但它是圣诞节后的第二天，那时会有大规模的促销活动，我不知道，各大公司和企业都会参与，所以你可以买到大幅打折的商品。我很少在节礼日去商店，因为它类似于“黑色星期五”，简直是一片混乱。是的，我不得不说，节礼日通常在英国更多地与吃剩菜联系在一起。许多家庭会在节礼日出去散步，试图消化掉摄入的大量食物。是的。
But yes, the etymology, I think, is not clear. So there's the idea. Some people say it's when you put your Christmas gifts back in their boxes, but that seems a bit weak. Another idea is that it's when you give your, historically, you give your household staff their Christmas boxes. So that's traditionally, I think, still the day when you might tip your delivery people or, you know, you give your gardener a tip or you give your rubbish man a tip. I see. Something like that. But all of that is at this point in
但确实，我认为它的词源并不明确。有一种说法是，有些人说这是你把圣诞礼物放回盒子里的时候，但这听起来有点牵强。另一种说法是，从历史上看，这是你给家政人员发放圣诞礼盒的时候。所以我认为，传统上这仍然是你可能会给快递员小费，或者给园丁小费，或者给垃圾清理工小费的日子。我明白了。类似这样的事情。但所有这些在现代都已经相当过时了。
the modern era, fairly archaic. Right. We, I mean, we have, I mean, technically we have a garbage I think they call them sanitation engineers but those are employed by the city I was struggling to think of the right term
对。我的意思是，我们……从技术上讲，我们有垃圾……我想他们称之为环境卫生工程师，但他们是由城市雇佣的。我刚才一直在想这个合适的术语。
yeah yeah well I mean I mean garbage men is like unofficially or garbage person but I mean on paper they're official title but they're paid by like tax
是啊，是啊，我的意思是，“垃圾工”是非正式的说法，或者叫“垃圾清理人员”，但从书面上看，他们有正式的头衔，但他们是由税收支付工资的。
tax dollars and like we don't have an official relationship I've never met any of the we see the trouble by and we do not have a gardener or any of those other things but
税款，而且我们之间没有正式的关系。我从来没见过他们中的任何一个，我们看到垃圾车经过，而且我们没有园丁或任何其他类似的人，但是……
anyways so anyways happy holidays happy holidays to you as well ben and family and friends um have you been i mean it's been we were talking about this before we started recording it's been like a few months it's been some months yeah either september or august since we've chatted which means that i mean if you have gone to cppcon oh yeah i did i did attend cppcon in september it was months ago uh but we haven't talked about that but i'm thinking you you must have i mean obviously i've been at a couple conferences
总之，总之，节日快乐。也祝你和你的家人朋友节日快乐。嗯，你最近怎么样？我的意思是，我们录音前还在聊这个，已经有几个月了。确实有几个月了，是的，自从我们上次聊天以来，要么是九月要么是八月，这意味着，如果你去了 CPPCon……哦，是的，我确实参加了九月份的 CPPCon，那是几个月前的事了，但我们还没聊过那个。但我认为你一定……我的意思是，显然我参加了几个会议。
but you must have been to at least CPP cons since then. Anyways, how is that? And how have things been in general? Things have been great. Things have been, you know, I've been same old, same old, quietly working. Attending CPPON, like you say, that was a lot of fun. That's right here on my doorstep, so I don't have to travel. This year I didn't even, so some years previously when I've given talks, and I almost,
但你从那以后至少参加过 CPPCon。总之，感觉怎么样？总体情况如何？一切都很棒。一切都……你知道，我还是老样子，安静地工作。参加 CPPCon，就像你说的，那真的很有趣。它就在我家门口，所以我不需要出差。今年我甚至……因为往年我做演讲的时候，我经常会订酒店房间，尽管离我只有 35 到 40 分钟的路程。早高峰大概半小时车程。挺好的。今年我没有订酒店，因为通常我会订，如果我是演讲者，会议会支付我的酒店费用，或者我的公司会支付。
I very often give a talk. And in previous years, when I've done that, I have got a hotel room, even though it's about 35, 40 minutes from me. half an hour in early morning traffic, I guess. It's good. This year I didn't get a hotel room because normally I would get a hotel room because the conference, if I'm a speaker, the conference would pay for my hotel or my company would.
但今年，Ava 让我待在家里。这其实挺好的，因为住在酒店虽然有利于走廊社交，有利于在酒店酒吧和大家聊到深夜，但我从来没在酒店房间睡好过。是的，所以能回家感觉很好，而且效果不错，还更省钱。
But this year, I'd, you know, Ava asked me to stay at home. And it was kind of nice, you know, because staying in the hotel room while it's good for the hallway track, it's good for those late nights in the hotel bar talking to folks, I would I never get good sleep in hotel rooms yeah so it was good to come back home and you know that was that worked well and cheaper yeah yeah I mean it's a I have always for the CPP North conference I was a seven minute city bike away from right the place so I always stayed at home although but now she and I recently moved and at least with traffic in the morning if we if I drove down, it would be potentially north of an hour. Right. So you're a little way outside the city now? Yeah, we're, I mean, we're still technically in Toronto proper, but just with traffic.
是啊，是啊。对于 CPP North 会议，我总是骑城市自行车七分钟就能到，所以我总是待在家里。虽然她和我最近搬家了，至少如果早上开车的话，可能需要一个多小时。所以你现在住在城外一点？是的，我的意思是，我们从技术上讲仍然在多伦多市区，但交通确实是个问题。
I mean, I think at nighttime, it's probably 25 minutes. But yeah, because everyone's going downtown. So anyways, I don't, I know, I mean, actually, I'm not sure if you've heard the news, but CPP North is no longer CPP North. They merged with the NDC conference circuit. Okay. Okay. Now it is NDC Toronto. I see. So Mike messaged me saying that NDC, saying about NDC Toronto, he didn't make it clear that that was what CP North had become. Yeah. But I can say that that conference clashes exactly with C++ now. It's the very same week.
我的意思是，我觉得晚上可能只要 25 分钟。但确实，因为每个人都要去市中心。总之，我不知道，我的意思是，其实我不确定你是否听说了这个消息，但 CPP North 不再是 CPP North 了。他们与 NDC 会议巡回赛合并了。好的。好的。现在它是 NDC 多伦多。我明白了。所以 Mike 发消息告诉我关于 NDC 多伦多的事，他没说清楚这就是 CPP North 演变而来的。但可以说，那个会议的时间正好与 C++ Now 冲突。就在同一周。
I haven't actually looked at the dates. Oh, there we go. So I Google NDC. And it's 5th to the 8th of May, which immediately I did think, well, you already said C++ now, but usually it's the first week of May. And it typically always collides with the weekend of a 10K race in Toronto that I like. Yeah. Well, C++ now, the last couple of years has been that earlier week, that straddling week between April and May. But it seems that this year or next year is going to go back to that first full week or second week. of May, which it always used to clash with Mother's Day as well. That's why people would
我还没查过日期。哦，找到了。我谷歌了一下 NDC。是 5 月 5 日到 8 日，我立刻想到，嗯，你刚才已经说了 C++ Now，但通常是在五月的第一周。而且它通常总是与多伦多我喜欢的一场 10 公里跑步比赛的周末冲突。是的，好吧，C++ Now 在过去几年里是在那个较早的周，也就是四月和五月交替的那一周。但看起来今年或明年它会回到五月的第一个完整周或第二周，这总是会和母亲节冲突。这就是为什么人们会……
leave early because that weekend of Mother's Day would be the closing weekend. Yeah, I know that because the 10K race that I like, it's called the Sporting Life 10K, and I like it because it's like the most downhill 10K race that I've ever run. So it gives you a little boost. It's always on Mother's Day. Right. Okay. Which is, I mean, my mom lives a the country so it's not a big deal but I know a lot of one of the guys in my run club you know he's got a partner and two kids and he's always talking about how he's got to clear it with the the wife that you know on Mother's Day he can go out and run this race and luckily it's at like 7 a.m. or something so you can be done the race and back home by 839 if you have
提前离开，因为母亲节那个周末会是闭幕周末。是的，我知道，因为我喜欢的那个 10 公里比赛叫“Sporting Life 10K”，我喜欢它是因为它是我跑过的下坡路段最多的 10 公里比赛。所以它会给你一点助力。它总是在母亲节。好的。我的意思是，我妈妈住在乡下，所以这没什么大不了的，但我知道我的跑步俱乐部里的一个人，他有伴侣和两个孩子，他总是说他得跟妻子商量，在母亲节那天他可以出去跑这场比赛。幸运的是，比赛在早上 7 点左右，所以如果你需要做早餐什么的，你可以在 8 点 39 分之前跑完回到家。但总之，我想人们将不得不……我的意思是，你可以两边都投递，如果被录取了……但我正在尝试查看 CFP（征稿启事）。它并没有明确显示 C++ Now 的征稿已经开始。我知道 NDC 多伦多的征稿截止到 12 月底。所以如果你在 2026 年新年前听到这个，你可以成为有史以来第一批在这一技术上全新的会议上演讲的人之一，但实际上它是第五届 CPP North，只是他们换了名字。所以我认为这是一个……
to make breakfast or whatever but anyways so I mean I guess people are going to have to I mean you could submit to both and if you get accepted, but I'm trying to check is the CFP call for papers. It doesn't scream to me that the call for papers for C++ now is open. I know for NDC Toronto, it's open until the end of December. So if you're listening to this, before the 2026 new year, you can be one of the first ever to speak at a technically new conference, but really it's the fifth CPP North, but they're going under the title. So I think it's a
部分，他们会有 C++ 轨道，但 NDC 总的来说是一个多语言的盛会。我想 N 在某个时候代表 .NET。所以有很多 C# 和 F#。哦，有趣。取决于版本，比如 NDC 奥斯陆更偏向于系统……
parts, they'll have a C++ track but it'll, NDC in general is like a polyglot crop. I think the N at one point stood for dot net. So there's a lot of C sharp and F sharp. Oh, interesting. Depending on the addition, like NDC Oslo is more of a systems
编程，或者不是系统，抱歉，我在想 NDC Tech Town，那个在奥斯陆郊外的。那更像是一个系统编程 C/C++ 课程或会议，而其他的，是的，就像我说的，视情况而定。总之，我想如果他们是 C++ 社区的人，就得做出选择。好的，所以征稿截止到年底，12 月底。
program, or not systems, sorry, I'm thinking NDC Tech Town, the one that's outside of Oslo. That's more of like a systems programming C C++ course or a conference, whereas other ones, yeah, like I said, depending. Anyway, so I guess people will have to choose if they are in the C++ community. Right. So the call for papers is till end of the year, end of December.
这很有趣。对于 NDC 多伦多，是的。对于 C++ Now，看起来还没……不，它要到一月份才开始。一直有一个问题，一种困境，就是你是在圣诞节前开放征稿，还是什么时候截止？因为，你知道，这段时间，真的是一年的最后一个月，很多人都在旅行，很多人可能甚至没有心情去准备会议提案。我很好奇提案在 NDC 会议上会如何筛选。
That's interesting. For NDC Toronto, yeah. For C++ now, it doesn't look to be... No, it hasn't been opening until January. There was always a question, a sort of dilemma of do you open the call for papers before Christmas, and when do you close it? Because, you know, this time, really the last month of the year, so many people are traveling, so many people are, maybe even not in the right frame of mind to put together a conference proposal. I wonder how the proposals are going to shake out in
我认为出于这个原因，C++ Now 改为在圣诞节后开放征稿。是的，我同意在新年开始后进行是一个更好的主意，因为在规划方面，你知道，即使是你想要做的演讲，就像，我不知道，这有点像新年决心。比如，我希望 26 年的路线图是什么？话虽如此，他们已经有了 3、6、9、11 位演讲者，包括 Jason Turner、Kate Gregory 还有 Richard Campbell。他联系非常紧密。他是 Dotnet Rocks 的联合主持人之一，这是较早、运行时间较长的播客之一。我不是 Dotnet Rocks 的活跃听众，因为我不做 dotnet 编程，但我听过几集，它们听起来非常有趣。
NDC. And I think for that reason, you know, CIPA now switch to opening the call for papers after Christmas. Yeah, I would agree that having it after the beginning of the New Year is a better idea because in terms of planning, you know, even the talks you want to give, like, I don't know, it's kind of like New Year's resolutions. Like, what, what do I want the roadmap to be for 26? That being said, they already have three, six, nine, 11 speakers, including Jason Turner and Kate Gregory and also Richard Campbell. He's very closely tied. He's one of the co-hosts of Dotnet Rocks, one of the older, longer running podcast. I'm not an active listener of Dotnet Rocks because I don't do dotnet programming, but I've listened to a few episodes and it's, they're very entertaining to listen to.
所以总之，他们已经有了一些演讲者。他们预计会有多少人？你可能不知道答案，但你认为他们预计会议会有多少人？CPP North 很小但在增长，我想，但过去几年仍然很小。那么 NDC 是想增加这个数字吗？我想是的，但这完全是我个人的猜测。我……我的意思是，我前几天给 Mike 发了消息，但他没有提到任何关于 Mike Dom（CPP North 的前组织者）的事，他没有提到任何关于他们计划的事。
So anyways, they've already got a number of speakers. Are they expecting how many, you maybe don't know the answer, but what would you say is regarding the number of people they're expecting at the conference? CPP North was small but growing, I think, but it was still pretty small these last few years. So is NDC looking to boost that number? I would imagine so, but that is just complete speculation on my part. I have, I mean, I did, or I messaged Mike the other day, but he didn't mention anything about Mike Dom, the previous organizer of CPP North, but he didn't mention anything about their plans.
我知道它是在一个新的地点举行，所以前两年，CPP North 是在 King Edward 酒店举行的，我相信是这个名字，那是一家非常豪华、花费昂贵的酒店，然后我想出于财务原因，那是 Omni 吗？去年是吗？所以我认为 Omni 和 King Edward 是同一个，我想 Omni 是酒店品牌，King Edward 是那家特定酒店的名字。然后过去两年，我今年没去，但前一年，我想是同一个地点，是由微软主办的。没错，这还可以，只是有点难进去，因为你知道，那是一栋企业大楼，你需要徽章之类的东西。
I know that it's being held at like a new location, so the first two years, CPP North was held at the King Edward Hotel, I believe it was called, which is a very fancy hotel that costs a lot of money and then I think for financial reasons that was it the omni this last year is that so I think the Omni the Omni is the same as the King Aubur I think Omni is the hotel brand and King Edward is the name of that specific hotel and then the last two years I wasn't there this year but the year before and I think it was the same location it was hosted by Microsoft that's right which was okay it was a little tricky to get into because it's, you know, a corporate building where you need badges and stuff.
我想现在我看到它是在威斯汀酒店举办的，那是一家酒店，你知道，和 King Edward 类似，会有会议空间。但那还在多伦多市中心吗？我假设是。是的。是的，威斯汀酒店，如果你熟悉多伦多，我相信，我不知道，我们 5% 的听众熟悉，就是那家坐落在杰克·莱顿渡轮码头顶上的酒店，渡轮去多伦多岛。所以如果你曾经坐渡轮去多伦多岛，它就是那家字面上就在旁边的酒店。所以它就在海滨。
And I think now I've seen that it's being hosted at the Westin, which is a hotel that, you know, similar to the King Edward will have like conference spaces. But it's still downtown Toronto then? I'm assuming. Yes. Yes. The Westin is, if you're familiar with Toronto, which I'm sure, I don't know, 5% of our listeners are, is the hotel that sits on top of the Jack Layton ferry terminal that goes to Toronto Island. So if you've ever taken the ferry to Toronto Island, it's the hotel that literally sits right next to that. So it's right on the waterfront.
他们实际上在顶层有一家餐厅，曾经叫 Talu 或 Tulu，它有点……它不旋转。就像 CN 塔顶部的餐厅叫 360，因为它会旋转。但威斯汀顶部的餐厅，它不旋转，但取决于你坐在哪里，它可以看到城市的不同部分。所以……总之，无论如何，我应该带一个真正了解实际情况的人来，我只是在胡编乱造……但我会这么想，我认为过去几年平均有 200 到 250 人，跨越四年，所以我认为 NDC，你知道，他们是一个更大的会议品牌，所以他们会吸引，你知道，C++ 之外不同社区的演讲者。所以是的，我不惊讶 Jason 会去，他至少周二去是有道理的。他已经有几年没去 C++ Now 了，因为会议太小，无法证明支出的合理性。而且，作为一名培训师，他需要去那些能接到工作的会议。是的。C++ Now 是，你知道，有影响力的人会去 C++ Now。
And they actually have a restaurant at the top that at one point was called Talu or Tulu, which is kind of a, it doesn't spin. Like the restaurant at the top of the CN Tower is called 360 because it spins. But the restaurant that's at the top of the west in, it doesn't spin, but depending on where you sit, it kind of looks out at different parts of the city. so um anyways anyway i should bring uh someone that actually knows more about the actual i'm just making stuff up about uh but i would imagine so i think in the last few years it was 200 250 people on average across the four years so i would imagine that nDC you know they're a bigger conference
然后你回到他们的公司，你可以说，让我们请人来做培训。我认为这在过去对人们来说发生过，但这些天，去参加另一个会议对他来说性价比更高。如果我错了请纠正我，因为我只在 2019 年去过，我甚至不记得他们是否报销差旅和住宿，但我很确定至少今天他们不报销。我想只针对志愿者。
brand so they're going to attract you know speakers in different communities outside of c++ so yeah and i'm not surprised that jason is going it makes sense that he would at least Tuesday. He hasn't been going to C++ now for a couple of years because it's too small of a conference to justify the outlay. And, you know, as a trainer, he needs to go to conferences where he can get work. Yeah. C++ now is, you know, there are influential people who go to C++ now
是的，这显然也会影响，你知道，如果你是一名培训师。就像，我总是想，你知道，我内心有一部分很想做培训，但……你称之为职业或日常工作，它会影响你想要去参加会议的愿望。第一，你停止了培训，所以你从中获得的收入就消失了，除此之外，你可能还要支付支出。所以这就像双重打击，就像上大学和工作一样，对吧？不仅你没有得到报酬，你还要付钱去上学。所以显然，你知道，不仅仅是代表 Jason，对于培训师和顾问来说，这在计算中占很大一部分。我是不是要去参加 X 会议，基本上就像损失了我正在赚取的收入，而且还得花钱。所以对于那些报销住宿和差旅的特定会议，显然这会使它比潜在的竞争会议更有吸引力两倍。我认为 NDC 确实会，再一次，应该请一位来自 NDC 的人来。但我过去参加过的 NDC 会议确实报销住宿和差旅。所以总之……我猜既然我们在谈论会议，CPPCon 你说很棒……我不确定你是否还记得那么久以前的事……是的，怎么样？嗯，真的很好。我能记得一些演讲……今年有一个新的轨道，我可能会记错名字，但类似于“职业与商业轨道”。好的……嗯……那个轨道的开场演讲，我会在不同的标签页上查看，以便我能弄对。我认为这是一个非常有趣的演讲，由……好的，我相信它叫“工程师也是用户 2”。
and you go back to their companies and you could say, let's get people in to do training. I think that has happened. for folks in the past, but these days, it's more bang for his buck to go to another conference. And correct me if I'm wrong, because I only went in 2019, and I don't even recall if they covered travel and accommodations, but I'm pretty sure at least today they don't. For volunteers only, I think.
由 Grace Allwin 演讲。我认为那是一个非常有趣的演讲。基础设施设计思维案例研究。那么演讲的高层论点是什么？Grace 在彭博社工作。她是，或者至少在演讲时是。也许她现在已经晋升了。
Yeah, which also obviously affects, you know, if you're a trainer. Like, I always think about, like, you know, there's a part of me that would love to do, like, training but the uh the what do you call it like career or day to day like it affects your your desire to want to go to a conference like one you're stopping doing training so you're the income that you're collecting from that like disappears and on top of that you potentially are paying you have an expenditure yeah so it's like a double whammy it's like going to university versus working right like not only are you not getting paid you're paying to go to school and so obviously you know not just speaking for jason but trainers and
她是技术基础设施部门的软件工程师。演讲是关于基础设施的用户体验，你知道，基础设施设计思维案例研究。所以工程师也是用户。所以她从事低级基础设施系统的工作，为彭博社的各个团队提供大规模计算支持，她的背景是用户体验和人机交互。
consultants in general. It's a huge part of the calculation of, am I going to go to conference X and basically like lose the income that I'm making plus also have to be spending. And so for certain conferences that are covering your accommodations and travel, obviously that's going to make it twice as attractive as potentially a competing conference. And I think NDC does, once again, should bring someone on from NDC. But the NDC conferences that I've been to in the past do cover accommodations and travel so anyways uh i guess seeing as we're talking about conferences CPP con you said it was great uh I'm not sure if you can recall that far back uh yeah how was it um it was really good I can recall some of the talks uh there was a new track this
所以演讲非常有趣，她展示了原型设计、用户访谈等，以改善用户体验，工程用户体验。
year I'm going to get the name wrong but it's something like career and business track okay um and um the opening session of the opening talk of that track, I'm going to look at it on different tabs so that I can get it right. I thought it was a really interesting talk by, okay, I believe it was called Engineers or Users 2.
有趣。听起来确实是一个很棒的演讲。我查了一下，不幸的是，它还没有上线。但在某个时候它会有的。我会留下一个陈旧的链接。不是陈旧？那是错误的词。未链接的链接。陈旧，我想是坏掉的意思。
By Grace Allwin. I thought that was a really interesting talk. A case study and design thinking for infrastructure. And so what's the high level kind of thesis of the talk? Grace works at Bloomberg. She is, or at least was at the time of the talk. Maybe she's advanced now.
占位符，是的。是的，是的。有很多演讲都很不错。我正在浏览一些我记得的演讲。Ben Sacks 做了一个关于实现你自己的原子操作的精彩演讲，这在某种程度上……
She's a software engineer in the Technology Infrastructure. And the talk was about UX for infrastructure, you know, a case study and design thinking for infrastructure. So engineers are users too. So she works on low level kind of infrastructural systems, powering computer at scale for the various teams. Bloomberg, and her background's in UX and HCI.
与我的演讲部分吻合，因为在裸机嵌入式上工作，我有一种非常有限的原子操作形式，当然不是完整的 std::atomic 接口。你知道，我使用的微控制器可以进行原子交换，但仅此而已。所以这是我做过的事情，有效地实现了原子操作，或者实现了……是的，实现了与原子操作相同的接口，但确保它对底层的微控制器运行良好。
And so the talk was kind of really interesting how she presented prototyping, user interviews, things like that for the betterment of the UX, the engineering UX.
有趣。那是 Ben Sacks，他说。Ben Sacks，S-A-K-S。好的。然后我还在等 Michael Case 的演讲，我的同事 Michael。他做了一个精彩的演讲。现在，我必须查一下，因为它不在我正在看的页面上。
Interesting. It does sound like a neat talk. I looked it up and it is, unfortunately, not online yet. But at some point it will be. I will leave a stale link. We're not stale? That's the wrong word. Unlinked link. Stale is, I guess, broken.
Michael Case，闪电演讲。Groove，特殊功能寄存器的异步处理？是的。所以 Groove 是……我们的库，就像标题所说，用于特殊功能寄存器的异步处理。所以嵌入式意义上的寄存器，不是指处理器寄存器，而是指对硬件具有特殊语义的内存位置。你知道，内存映射 I/O 是一个典型的用例。Groove 建立在我们的发送者和接收者库之上。
A placeholder, yes. Yeah, yeah. There were quite a few talks that were good. I'm just looking through some of the talks to the ones I remember. Ben Sacks gave a great talk about implementing your own Atomics, which kind of
所以它呈现出……相同的接口，无论你的寄存器确实是内存映射的，只是简单的读或写，还是你的寄存器可以通过网络访问，就像在片上网络或其他你可能拥有的东西上一样，但某种用于访问的异步机制。对，所以 Groove 为这两种情况呈现相同的接口，即基于发送者的接口。在内存映射 I/O 的情况下，当然，它会坍缩成一次读或写。而在真正的异步访问的情况下，那么你就会得到所有随发送者和接收者开箱即用的东西，比如错误通道和取消等等。所以这就是 Michael 演讲的内容，那个在发送者和接收者之上的接口。
meshed with my talk in part because working on bare metal embedded I have a very limited form of atomics, certainly not the full stood atomic interface. You know, the microcontroller I work with can do atomic exchange, but not much more. And so that's something that I've done effectively implementing atomics or implementing, yeah, implementing the same interfaces to the atomic, but making sure that it works well for the underlying microcontroller.
这是英特尔开源的吗？是的。有趣。是的，它是我们的开源库之一。Groove 代表“通用寄存器操作优化器 5”，如果你一定要看的话。因为恰好内部版本是第 4 版，所以当我们想缩写时，他选择了 Groove。非常有趣。
Interesting. That was Ben Sacks, he said. Ben Sacks, S-A-K-S. Okay. And then I'm still waiting for Michael Case's talk, my colleague Michael. He gave a great talk. Now, I have to look it up because it's not on the page. I'm looking at.
我的意思是，我谷歌了 Groove，G-R-O-O-V，和 GitHub，它是第三个搜索结果，至少对我来说是这样。第一个是 Facebook 研究的 Groove，拼写完全一样。尽管它是一个存档的仓库，而且星数比英特尔的仓库少。我的意思是，诚然，Facebook 的那个有 24 个星，英特尔的有 43 个，所以并不是一个比另一个多出几个数量级。但有趣的是，Facebook 的那个排在前面，尽管它已存档且星数更少。但我会为感兴趣的人链接英特尔的那个。我也会链接，就像我说的，所有的链接，即使演讲还没出来，也会在节目说明中。
Michael Case, Lightning Talks. Groove, asynchronous handling of special function registers? Yes. So Groove is. Our library, like the title says, for asynchronous handling of special function registers. So registers in the embedded sense, meaning not processor registers, but memory locations that have special semantics to the hardware. You know, memory mapped I.O. is a typical use case. And Groove sits on top of our senders and receivers library.
我从来不说这个。我假设人们只是去网站。永远不要去你的播客播放器里的那一集，因为我不会回过头去更新那里的链接。我只去更新网站节目说明中的链接，因为我可以从一个 IDE 完成所有这些。而播客播放器，你必须去一堆不同的网页。
And so it presents the... same interface whether your register is indeed memory mapped and it's just a plain old read or write or your register could be accessed across a network as it were across a network on chip or whatever you might have but some kind of asynchronous mechanism for access right so groove presents the same interface i.e a senders based interface for both of those situations and in the case of With the memory wrapped I.O., of course, it collapses down to a single read or write. And in the case of the true asynchronous access, then you get all of the things that come out of the box with sends and receivers like error channel and cancellation and things like that. So that's what Michael's talk is about, that interface on top of senders and receivers.
好的，所以 Michael Case。我的意思是，你实际上还没看过那个演讲，你说。我的意思是，我亲自看了，但它还没在线提供。哦，好的，好的。我假设 CPPCon 正在做那种缓慢发布的事情，你知道，一周一次。是的，完全正确。是的。他们试图迎合算法。
Is this open source out of Intel? Yes. Interesting. Yes, it's one of our open source libraries. Groove stands for generic register operation optimizer 5, if you must look. Because it just happened that the internal version was on version 4, so when we were thinking up an acronym, he went with Groove. Very interesting.
迎合算法。所以那是一个很棒的演讲。我做了一个关于……现在我忘了演讲的名字，但它是关于将抽象带到非常底层的。我们有另一个库，我们有一个标准扩展库，这有点像……我认为它是命名你的 Utils 文件夹的社会可接受的方式。就像每个人都有这种不适合放在其他任何地方的东西的集合，他们称之为实用程序或 Utils。你所做的是你称它们为标准扩展。你把它们做成一个开源库，现在你就有了一些体面。
I mean, I googled Groove, GR, O, V, and GitHub, and it's the third top result, at least for me. The first one is Facebook researches groove, which is spelt the identical way. Although it's an archived repo and has less stars than the Intel repo. I mean, admittedly, the Facebook one has 24 stars and the Intel one has 43, so it's not like one's order of magnitudes more. But interesting that the Facebook one comes up first, even though it's archived and has less stars. but I will link the Intel one for folks that are interested. And I will also link, like I said, all the links, even if the talks aren't out, will be in the show notes.
但是，是的，很大程度上源于我为团队做代码审查，帮助团队成员，审视我们编写的代码，并试图提高其中的抽象水平。所以，你知道，在嵌入式底层工作，大量的位操作，你知道，把东西移到正确的位置。这样它们就会在寄存器的正确字段中，很多这样的事情，只是……当然，你可以，你可以做到，但我们……
And I never say this. I assume people just go to the website. Don't ever go to the episode in your podcast player because I do not retrospectively go back and update the links there. I only go up and go and update the links in the website show notes because I can do that all from a single. IDE versus the podcast player. You have to go to a bunch of different website pages.
并没有在那个领域比 1972 年 C 语言能做的事情进步多少，诸如此类。特别是整数提升非常糟糕，任何时候你对一个数字进行操作，它几乎肯定会变成 int，对吧？因为，或者至少是一个 unsigned int，因为很多这些东西，你知道，通用数据类型是 uint32。通常你是在处理 uint16 或 uint8。你是在处理无符号的小整数值，
Okay, so Michael Case. I mean, and you actually haven't seen that talk, you said. I mean, I saw it in person, but it's not yet available online. Oh, okay, okay. And I assume CBPCon is doing the thing where they slowly release, you know, once a week ago. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. They're trying to pander to the algorithm.
你在移位、相加、或运算，每次你做这样的事情时，整数提升就会困扰你，对吧？所以这里的一个例子是，你通常看到的一件事是涉及移位、掩码、或和与的表达式。你看到它们充满了强制类型转换的垃圾，因为人们，你知道，在制造，试图保护自己免受整数提升的影响，这，这都很好。你必须这样做，但它只是，它使代码变得难以阅读。你最终得到，你知道，不是每个人都想每次都推理……
Hander to the algorithm. So that was a great talk. I gave a talk on, and now I'm forgetting the name of the talk, but it was about bringing abstraction to the really low level. We have another library, we have a standard extensions library, which is kind of like, I think of it as the socially acceptable way to name your Utils folder. It's like everyone has this collection of things which don't really fit anywhere else and they call utilities or Utils. What you do is you call them standard extensions. You make them an open source library, and now you have some respectability.
也许有些人不知道，而另一些人只是想减轻认知负荷。所以你最终会在子表达式的子表达式上进行强制类型转换。你知道，即使是一行简单的代码，本应很简单，却被所有的强制类型转换弄得乱七八糟。例如。
But, yeah, a lot of it came out of me doing code reviews for my team, helping folks on my team, looking at the kind of code that we write and trying to raise the level of abstraction there. So, you know, working down at the embedded layer, tons of things like bit twiddling, you know, shifting things into the right place. so they'll be in the right field of the register lots of things like that that just sure you can you can do it but we haven't
所以，你知道，当我看到这样的代码时，我想，让我们做抽象吧。你知道，单行函数调用，单行函数模板实际上是免费的，对吧？这里没有运行时成本。编译器会 100% 地内联它。对。它会返回你要求的正确类型。你知道，所以你可以说，给我一个位掩码。我希望它是，是的，所以 uint16_t，
really come a long way in that area above what see could do in 1972 sort of thing and in particular integral promotions are very bad any time you have an operation on a number it's going to almost certainly become an int, right? Because, or at least an unsigned it, because a lot of these things are, you know, the lingua franco data type is the uint 32. Quite often you're working with uint 16s or you in 8s. You're working at unsigned small integral values,
我希望它在这些位之间，对吧？为什么每次我用长代码写出来时都要重新发明它，而你可以用完全相同的成本要求你想要的东西？就是那种事情。这是一个非常小的例子。是的，这让我想起了 Louis Dion 的演讲，
which you're shifting and adding and oaring around, and every time you do something like that, integral promotion just bites you, right? And so an example here is one of the things you typically see is expressions involving shifts and masks and oars and hands. And you see them full of just cruft of casts because people are, you know, making, trying to protect themselves against integral promotions, which is, which is all very good. You have to do that, but it just, it makes the code horrible to read. you end up with, you know, not everyone wants to reason about every time
以及其他一些做元编程演讲的人，你看到像这些函数的标准库版本，它们有无数的强制类型转换和 decltype。你明白那是正确的，你知道，但你看到那些代码，你只是觉得，哦，天哪。所以是的，我想你在推销。
and maybe some people don't know and other people just want to take out the cognitive load. So you end up with casts on sub-expressions of sub-expression sort of thing. You know, even with a simple line, a single line of code which should be simple, which is encraftified by all the casts. For example.
如果有一种方法可以插入一层抽象并隐藏那些东西，为什么不这样做呢？对，对。而在位掩码的情况下，你知道，有陷阱，比如，所以通常在嵌入式中，在数据表中你会发现寄存器中的位或字段
So, you know, when I came to code like this, I thought, let's just make abstractions. You know, one-line function calls, one-line function templates are effectively free, right? There's no runtime cost here. The compiler's going to inline that 100% of the time. Right. It's going to give you back the correct type that you asked for. You know, so you can say things like, give me a bit mask. and I want it to be, yeah, so you're in 16T,
在寄存器内部，因为我们在处理子字级别、子字节级别的东西，对吧？我们在处理单个位。字段通常被指定为包含性的。所以它会说最低有效位、最高有效位、包含范围，对吧？不像一个……
and I wanted between these two bits, right? Why reinvent that every time I write that out longhand in code where you can just ask for exactly what you want for exactly the same cost? It's that kind of thing. That's a very small example. Yeah, that reminds me of the Louis Dion talks
半开范围，而是一个包含范围。所以如果你编写天真地计算位掩码的代码，你可能会遇到这样的事情，比如，意外地按其宽度移动值，这是未定义的行为，对吧？你想包含那个最高位。所以如果你通过移动 1 加位然后减 1 来天真地做它以获得下面设置的所有位，好吧，现在你可能已经按类型的位宽移动了。对。对。对。诸如此类的事情。当然，你知道，有经验的程序员知道那种事情，
and a handful of other folks that give these metaprogramming talks and you see like the standard ease version of these functions that have just a bigillion casts and decal types. And you understand that that's like the correct, you know, but you see that code and you're just like, oh, my goodness. So yeah, I guess you're pitching.
但这是另一件只会使调用点复杂化或使代码复杂化的事情。你不如把它打包在抽象中。所以是的，这样你就不用去想它了。是的。有趣。我查了一下，因为我有完整的日程表。你做了，似乎是两次演讲。我猜这一个对应于标题“API 结构和技术：代码审查的经验教训”。是的，就是那个。是正确的，另一个，因为我确定听众现在在想，等等，有两个……
If there's a way that you can insert a layer of abstraction and hide that stuff, why not do that instead of? Right, right. And in that case of a bit mask, you know, there are pitfalls like, so typically an embedded, in data sheets you find you find the bits in a register or the fields
是“日志库的演变”，是的，那没有被录音，那是一个开放内容会议。好的……这就是为什么你应该去参加会议，伙计们……我实际上是在和我参加的最后一个会议的技术总监交谈，我不断发展的观点之一是，实际上在远程工作和分布式团队等时代，会议实际上比以前更重要，因为，你知道，我没有饮水机聊天，你知道吗？就像，我妻子总是开玩笑。哦，你做了这么多播客，等等。
inside a register because we're dealing with things at the sub-word level at the sub-byte level, right? We're dealing with individual bits. And the fields are usually specified as inclusive. So it'll say least significant bit, most significant bit, inclusive range, right? Not like a
真的有必要吗？我说，嗯，我的意思是，播客有点像是大流行时期生活的结果，想要和人交谈。是的。我的意思是，我们录制这些对话，但实际上，你知道，如果我们不录制它们，它们也会发生。这是一个给朋友打电话聊一小时的借口。人们可能不知道这一点，但我们实际上过去常常……
half-open range, but an inclusive range. And so if you write code that computes bit masks naively, you can run into things like, well, accidentally shifting the value by its width, which is undefined behavior, right? You want to include that top bit. So if you do it naively by shifting one plus the bit and then minus one to get all of the bits set below, well, now you've shifted potentially by the bit width of the type. Right. Right. Right. things like that. And of course, you know, experienced programmers know that kind of thing,
不是特别频繁，但，你知道，我们尝试一年做几次。我们只是跳上电话，只是，你知道，因为会议没有发生。而且，你知道，虚拟会议，我想说，它们比什么都没有好吗？是的。但也，它们太累人了，以至于，你知道，面对面的会议很累人。但虚拟会议，特别是如果你在演讲，在现实生活中面对面演讲要好得多，当你结束时。是的。而且它不会变成黑屏，你只是像独自在一个安静的……
but it's another thing which just complicates call sites or complicates code. You might as well just package it up in the abstraction. So yeah, so that you don't have to think about it. Yeah. Interesting. And I looked it up because I've got the full schedule. You gave, it seems two talks. And I'm guessing that this one corresponds to the title API structure and technique colon learnings from code review. Yes, that's the one. is correct and the other one because i'm sure the listener's thinking now wait there's two
房间里，这要好得多。总之，这只是……是的，会议也是，你知道，你为你的职业生涯能做的可能最重要的事情就是去参加会议，我想，对大多数人来说肯定是的。如果你是会议组织者，你想推销这一点吗？因为如果我是雇主……好吧，因为有些人可能会听到“这对你的职业生涯很有好处”，并不意味着你一定会换公司。所以我认为大家担心的是，会议组织者不想这么说，因为听起来就像是：“哦，我们把你送到会议上，结果一年后你就不在我们公司工作了。”
was the evolution of a logging library yes that was a that was not recorded that was an open content session okay um which is why you should go to the conferences folks uh i was literally talking to the last conference i was at the technical director that i my one of my evolving views is that actually in the age of remote work and you distributed teams et cetera et cetera that like conferences are actually even more important than they were before because, you know, I don't, I don't have the water cooler chats, you know? Like, my wife jokes all the time. Oh, you got so many podcasts, blah, blah, blah.
不，我认为他们绝对想这么说。好吧，我是会议组织者。请说服我为什么这应该成为宣传标语。嗯，你混淆了两件事。比如，去参加会议以促进你的职业生涯并不一定意味着换公司。这意味着拓宽你的视野。这意味着把你学到的东西带回你现在的公司，这样你就可以改进，你知道，改进一切，改进你团队的工作方式，改进你思考的事情。这就是我职业生涯的过程，你知道，肯定是在……
Isn't really necessary? And I was like, well, I mean, the podcast kind of came out of living, you know, pandemic times and like wanting to talk to people. Yeah. I mean, we record these conversations, but really, you know, they would happen if we wouldn't record them. It's an excuse to call up a friend and chat for an hour. People don't probably know that, but we actually used to,
十几岁的时候。另外，留住你也是一家好公司的目标。而且，你知道，所以如果你想去参加会议，而公司不让你去，因为它认为这样做你会离开，那么公司在留住你方面已经有问题了，对吧？这是一个很好的观点。是的，我的意思是，这是真的。我的意思是，我们第一次见面……我的意思是，在我们见面之前我就知道你是谁，因为你有很多在线演讲，但我们第一次见面是在 C++ Now，Bryce 和我第一次见面是在湾区的一个 C++ 聚会上。所以是的，我的意思是，我完全同意。但我曾经和一位会议组织者交谈过，基本上说了类似这样的话。就像，没有什么比从职业角度……我不喜欢这个词……
not super frequently, but, you know, we try and do it a couple times a year. we would just hop on a call and just, you know, because conferences weren't happening. And, you know, the virtual ones, I want to say, were they better than nothing? Yes. But also, too, they were like so exhausting in a way than like, you know, in person conferences are exhausting. But virtual conferences, especially if you're speaking, just it is so much better to give a talk in real life in person where when you're done. Yeah. And it doesn't go to a black screen and you're just like by yourself in a quiet.
频率不是特别高，但你知道，我们尽量一年做几次。我们只是会打个电话，因为当时没有线下会议。你知道，虚拟会议，我想说，它们比什么都没有强吗？是的。但它们也以一种方式让人精疲力竭，就像线下会议让人精疲力竭一样。但虚拟会议，特别是如果你在演讲的话，在现实生活中面对面演讲要好得多，当你讲完的时候。是的。它不会变成一个黑屏，让你独自待在一个安静的地方。
room it is it is so much better anyways it's just that uh yeah conferences are also you know probably the number one thing you can do for your career is to go to a conference i think certainly for for most people if you're a conference organizer do you want to pitch that though because if i'm a employer well because some people might hear is great for your career doesn't mean you're going to switch companies. So that's the worry, I think, is that conference organizer doesn't want to say that because it sounds like, oh, we're going to send you to a conference and then in a year you're not going to be at our company anymore.
房间里，这真的好多了。总之，会议可能确实是你职业生涯中能做的第一件事，我认为对大多数人来说肯定如此。如果你是会议组织者，你想推销这个观点吗？因为如果我是雇主，有些人可能会听到这对你的职业生涯很有帮助，但这并不意味着你要跳槽。所以我认为担心的是，会议组织者不想这么说，因为听起来像是，哦，我们要送你去参加会议，然后一年后你就不在我们公司了。
No, they absolutely want to say that, I think. All right, I'm a conference organizer. Sell me on why this should be the tagline. Well, you're conflating two things. Like, going to a conference to further your career doesn't mean necessarily changing companies. It means broadening your horizon. It means taking back what you learn to your current company so that you can improve, you know, improve everything, improve the way your team works, improve the things you think about. That is the course of my career, you know, certainly in the
不，我认为他们绝对想这么说。好吧，我是会议组织者。说服我为什么这应该成为标语。嗯，你把两件事混为一谈了。去参加会议以促进你的职业发展并不一定意味着换公司。这意味着开阔你的视野。这意味着把你学到的东西带回你现在的公司，这样你就可以改进，你知道，改进一切，改进你团队的工作方式，改进你的思考方式。这就是我职业生涯的过程，你知道，肯定是在
sort of mid-teens. And separately, it is a good company's goal to keep you at that company. and you know so if if you want to go to conferences and the company won't send you because it thinks that by doing so you would leave the company already has problems keeping you right and that's a great point uh yeah i mean it's true i mean we first met uh i mean i knew who you were before we met because you had a bunch of talks online but we first met at c++ now and bryce and i first met at a c plus plus meet up in the bay area so yeah it is i mean i completely agree. But I had talked to a conference organizer once and said something basically along the lines of this. Like there's nothing better that you can do from like a career. I don't like the word
十几岁的时候。另外，留住员工是好公司的目标。你知道，如果如果你想去参加会议，而公司因为认为这样做会导致你离开而不让你去，那么公司本身在留住你方面就已经有问题了，这是一个很好的观点。是的，我的意思是这是真的，我们第一次见面，我的意思是，在我们见面之前我就知道你是谁，因为你在网上有很多演讲，但我们第一次见面是在 C++ Now，我和布莱斯第一次见面是在湾区的一个 C++ 聚会上，所以是的，我的意思是，我完全同意。但我曾经和一位会议组织者谈过，基本上说了类似这样的话。就像没有什么比这更能促进你的职业发展了。我不喜欢这个词
networking because a lot of times it's not like I walk into a room and it's like, I'm ready to network. You know, it's like that's not what it is. But it's like you have conversations, your idea sharing. And, you know, I don't, I'm never actively thinking like now is the time to go and network. I just like you're around other passionate, excited people that want to share their. things that they're passionate about and excited about and it's just like it's just an amazing experience and yes and you're you're sharing your ideas and in turn you're learning so much I learned my goodness the when I first went to CPP now in 2014 yeah and it was the first conference I'd been to and I was coming from you know I was an
网络，因为很多时候并不是说我走进一个房间，然后就想“我准备好去建立人脉了”。你知道，事情并不是那样的。而是你进行了交谈，分享了想法。而且，你知道，我从来不会主动去想“现在是去建立人脉的时候了”。我只是觉得，当你和一群充满激情、兴奋、想要分享他们所热爱和兴奋的事物的人在一起时，这简直是一种奇妙的体验。是的，你在分享你的想法，反过来你也在学习很多东西。天哪，我第一次去 CPP Now 是在 2014 年，那是我参加的第一个会议，当时我是一个
experienced game industry C++ engineer but the you know the way my eyes were opened by C++ plus now is unbelievable I learned so many things that that first year that second year I went I was it was just like drinking from a firehouse yeah yeah yeah it is uh thinking about yeah the phase of your career where you still have like you don't know how much you don't know like now I know how much I don't know and every day that goes by I know I learn more you know that your quote or not your quote but I heard it from you you know, the larger your island of knowledge, the longer your shore of ignorance, I'm at the part now, the phase of whatever my career where my island of knowledge is quite
经验丰富的游戏行业 C++ 工程师，但 C++ Now 开阔我眼界的方式简直令人难以置信。那第一年我学到了太多东西，第二年我去的时候，感觉就像是在用消防水带喝水一样。是的，是的，这确实是……想到你职业生涯的那个阶段，你仍然不知道自己有多无知。就像现在，我知道自己有多无知，而且随着每一天的过去，我学到的更多。你知道那句名言，或者说不是你的名言，但我从你那里听到的：你的知识岛屿越大，你的无知海岸线就越长。我现在处于职业生涯的那个阶段，我的知识岛屿相当
large, so I'm not, you know, but there's a point where you don't even realize how much you don't know, and it is intoxicating for someone that like myself and you and others, I assume, that like to learn, that like to, you know, I've heard another quote that a new perspective increases your IQ by 30 points, is, you know, plus or minus, you know, you can disagree with the, whatever IQ, but in general, just like learning a new paradigm program language-wise to solve a type of problem, it is intoxicating. And now like that, like when you're drinking from that fire hose at that phase of your career, we don't really get to do that anymore. Like, it is less often that you're going to go and like talk after talk after talk. You're getting
大，所以，你知道，但有一个阶段是你甚至没有意识到自己有多无知，这对于像我、你以及我想象中的其他人这样喜欢学习的人来说，是令人陶醉的。我听过另一句名言，说一个新的视角能让你的智商提高 30 点，加减法嘛，你可以不同意关于智商的说法，但总的来说，就像学习一种新的编程语言范式来解决一类问题一样，这是令人陶醉的。现在，当你处于职业生涯的那个阶段，用消防水带喝水时，我们真的再也无法那样做了。就像，你不太可能一场接一场地去听讲座。你正在
like a new idea and a new thing. It still happens, just not at that rate. But yeah, the first time I attended was 2019. And yeah, it is a, yeah, thinking about it. Doesn't give me a sense of, like, jealous of my younger self, but just like, it is a very amazing experience to be at that phase of your career where there's just so much that you don't know. And basically every talk you watch, you're coming away with, like, some new way to think about solving a problem. Yeah. I had never practiced generic programming. I was, the code bases I was working in back in early, early teens, they were still firmly with the foot in the early 2000s object-oriented mold, right?
获得一个新想法和新事物。这种情况仍然会发生，只是频率没那么高了。但确实，我第一次参加是在 2019 年。是的，想到这一点，并不会让我对年轻时的自己感到嫉妒，但确实，处于职业生涯的那个阶段，有那么多你不知道的东西，这是一种非常奇妙的体验。基本上你观看的每一场讲座，你都会带着一些思考问题的新方法离开。是的。我以前从未实践过泛型编程。我早年，也就是十几岁时工作的代码库，仍然牢牢地停留在 21 世纪初的面向对象模式中，对吧？
So they were certain, and they were, you know, to some extent, if you work at a company where there are lots of people who have been there a long time and where the average tenure is high, then it tends to be the case that you are sheltered from outside influences. You know, you've got a code base that might be 10, 15, maybe even 20 plus years old. there are patents in there which are repeated, tried, tested, but at some point, once you've learned everything you have to learn from that code base, there isn't going to be any new stuff going in there. There isn't going to be these kind of revelatory things. So you need to make an effort to stretch your view. So when I came to Aspern in 2014, I had never heard of
所以它们是确定的，而且在某种程度上，如果你在一家有很多老员工、平均任期很长的公司工作，那么你往往会被隔绝在外部影响之外。你知道，你有一个可能已经有 10、15，甚至 20 多年历史的代码库。里面有一些模式是重复的、经过尝试和测试的，但在某个时候，一旦你从那个代码库中学到了所有该学的东西，就不会再有任何新东西进去了。不会再有这种启示性的东西了。所以你需要努力去扩展你的视野。所以当我 2014 年来到 Aspern 时，我从未听说过
Alex Steppenoff. I had never heard of generic programming. I didn't know EOP. And I learned all about those things. Also, there were plenty of like just techniques in the code, which a couple of one or two of which I had still began to notice and I didn't have words for, right? And if you don't have, if you don't know what something is called, then you can't search for it effectively. Right. So one, you can, you know, I had, I had, I had, independent. discovered type erasure, but I had no idea to call it type erasure. Right, right. And so I wasn't able to link it to anything else until I came to Aspen and talk to other
Alex Steppenoff。我从未听说过泛型编程。我不知道 EOP。我学习了所有这些东西。此外，代码中还有很多技巧，其中一两个我开始注意到，但我没有词汇来描述它们，对吧？如果你不知道某样东西叫什么，你就无法有效地搜索它。对吧。所以，你知道，我曾经独立发现了类型擦除，但我根本不知道把它叫作类型擦除。对，对。所以我无法将它与任何其他东西联系起来，直到我来到 Aspen 并与其他
folks. And I described this pattern. I'm like, and you know, I saw this pattern in the code and I think it might be useful. And it does this thing and they're like, sounds like type erasure. You know, they really knew that. And this was like a light bulb moment for me. Yeah. Yeah, I can think of several moments like that.
人交谈。我描述了这个模式，我说，你知道，我在代码中看到了这个模式，我认为它可能很有用。它做了这件事，他们说，听起来像是类型擦除。你知道，他们真的知道。这对我来说是一个顿悟时刻。是的，是的，我能想到好几个这样的时刻。
Yeah, that it's, whether it's an algorithm name or a technique or even like an individual. Like I remember talking to David's ankle at the C++ now. That was the first conference I went to. And I was just, I was in the middle of like falling in love with Haskell. And I was just like, man, like, do people know about Haskell? Like, why are we doing the C++ thing? Like, you know, the lambda quote unquote syntax is so much better. You know, like I think people, if people take a look, they'll really like what they see.
是的，无论是算法名称、技术，甚至是一个人。我记得在 C++ Now 上和 David Sankle 交谈。那是我参加的第一个会议。我当时正处于爱上 Haskell 的过程中。我当时想，天哪，人们知道 Haskell 吗？为什么我们要搞 C++？你知道，所谓的 lambda 语法要好得多。你知道，我想如果人们看一看，他们会真的很喜欢他们所看到的。
Anyways, and David Sankle, at the time, his favorite language, he said wasn't even Haskell. He's like, you should check out Egg Da. Egg does even better than Haskell. And then I can't remember if it was you or David that said, have you heard of Bartaj Maluski? Because I was thinking, like, you know, I feel like if people take a look at this language, like, well, C++ is no one's going to want to do it anymore. And then he's like, well, do you know who Bartaj Maluski? I've never heard that name. And which is funny now because, you know, I've covered his book and, you know, I've chatted with him in person at conference.
总之，David Sankle 当时说他最喜欢的语言甚至不是 Haskell。他说你应该看看 Agda。Agda 甚至比 Haskell 更好。然后我不记得是你还是 David 说，你听说过 Bartaj Maluski 吗？因为我当时想，你知道，我觉得如果人们看一眼这种语言，好吧，C++ 就没人想用了。然后他说，你知道 Bartaj Maluski 是谁吗？我从来没听过这个名字。这很有趣，因为现在，你知道，我已经读过他的书，而且，你知道，我在会议上亲自和他聊过天。
and had him speak at meetups that I've run. But at that time, like you said, you'd never heard of Stepanov. And, like, now, to think of a time where you hadn't heard of Stepanov, like, where you are now in your career. It's almost comical to think of that time. But anyways, David's point, I think it was David. He's like, oh, yeah, like, Bartaj basically found functional programming and was, like, you know, basically, like, touched by the hand of God and became, like, a prophet for spreading
还让他在我举办的聚会上发言。但在那个时候，就像你说的，你从未听说过 Stepanov。而且，现在回想起来，在你职业生涯的这个阶段，你竟然没听说过 Stepanov，这简直有点滑稽。但总之，David 的观点，我想是 David，他说，哦，是的，Bartaj 基本上发现了函数式编程，就像，你知道，基本上被上帝之手触碰过，成为了传播
the functional program. and for a number of years was giving basically functional programming talks in C++ template metaprogramming. So there's a bunch of talks that you can find online from C++ now where every year he was showing some new technique that you could do at compile time in C++. So now... Or go ahead.
函数式编程的先知。并且有几年时间，他基本上是在 C++ 模板元编程中进行函数式编程的讲座。所以你可以在网上找到很多来自 C++ Now 的讲座，他每年都在展示一些你可以在 C++ 编译时完成的新技术。所以现在……或者你继续。
I have a segue which is that this year Michael Case was learning Haskell and doing advent of code. In Haskell? All right. So here we go. Avin of Code, folks. All right. So Ben and I recorded what you are about to listen to, if you want to, before what you just
我有一个过渡，那就是今年 Michael Case 正在学习 Haskell 并进行 Advent of Code。用 Haskell？好吧。那么我们开始吧，各位，Advent of Code。好吧。所以 Ben 和我录制了你即将听到的内容，如果你想的话，在刚才你
finished listening to. So I ended up taking our recording, cutting it in half, and then doing a one rotate, aka swapping the order. Because I figured the conference slash C++ talk would be a little bit more interesting. What you're about to listen to is us. or Ben, explaining teletext and the bamboozle quiz, and then us taking a bamboosal quiz. Happy holidays, folks.
听完的内容之前。所以我最终拿到了我们的录音，把它切成两半，然后做了一个旋转，也就是交换了顺序。因为我觉得会议/C++ 讲座会更有趣一点。你即将听到的是我们，或者说 Ben，解释图文电视和 Bamboozle 测验，然后我们进行 Bamboozle 测验。节日快乐，各位。
So teletext was a system before the internet when TV was analog. So it's defunct now. I forget when the last teletext was broadcast, but everything now is digital TV. And so we don't need it anymore. We have other things. But basically, if you remember back to, like, the BBC Micro, the BBC Micro had, well, I'm asking you to remember, but maybe you don't remember exactly, but somebody will, had a Mode 7 display, had a display of 40 columns by 25 lines of characters. It turns out you can fit that page into the analog TV signal in the vertical blank.
所以图文电视是互联网出现之前，电视还是模拟信号时的一种系统。所以现在已经废弃了。我忘了最后一次图文电视广播是什么时候，但现在一切都是数字电视了。所以我们不再需要它了。我们有其他东西。但基本上，如果你还记得 BBC Micro，BBC Micro 有，好吧，我是在要求你回忆，但也许你记得不准确，但总有人会记得，它有一个 Mode 7 显示，有 40 列乘 25 行字符的显示。事实证明，你可以把那个页面放入垂直消隐期的模拟电视信号中。
Right, so in the analog TV signal, there's a bit of downtime the signal between frames. It's called the vertical blank. And there's just enough space there to fit some effectively digital information, a 40 by 25 screen of text and, you know, graphical characters made from text, right? So like in the old style of box drawing characters and things like that. And that's what teletext was. So on every channel in the TV signal, in the analog TV signal, you put these pages in the vertical blanks and you cycle them, right?
对，所以在模拟电视信号中，帧与帧之间有一点停机时间。它被称为垂直消隐期。那里有足够的空间来容纳一些有效的数字信息，一个 40x25 的文本屏幕，以及由文本组成的图形字符，对吧？就像旧式的方框绘制字符之类的东西。这就是图文电视。所以在电视信号的每个频道上，在模拟电视信号中，你把这些页面放在垂直消隐期中，然后循环播放它们，对吧？
So the way it worked was that every page had a three-digit index. And so every TV had a text mode where you could switch TV into a mode which would decode this information. and display, instead of the regular TV signal, display the teletext signal. And then you would type in the page number, and 100 was kind of like the default, the index page, right? So you hit the text button, and it shows page 100. And then you type in, I don't know,
所以它的工作方式是每个页面都有一个三位数的索引。所以每台电视都有一个文本模式，你可以把电视切换到一种模式，解码这些信息，并显示图文电视信号，而不是常规的电视信号。然后你输入页码，100 就像是默认的索引页，对吧？所以你按下文本按钮，它显示第 100 页。然后你输入，我不知道，
300 for sports news or 500 for weather or whatever it might be. There were, you know, on the hundreds were the main indices, and on the tens were the sort of subindices often. and it was just a index directory of all kinds of useful information, like weather, sports, travel information, and one of them on Channel 4 that my sister and I used to play as teenagers was the Fun and Game section. I think it was page 470, if I remember right?
300 看体育新闻，或者 500 看天气，或者其他什么。你知道，百位数是主要索引，十位数通常是子索引。它只是一个包含各种有用信息的索引目录，比如天气、体育、旅行信息，其中一个在第 4 频道，我和我妹妹十几岁时经常玩的是“娱乐与游戏”部分。如果我没记错的话，应该是第 470 页？
I'm sure there's a few listeners nodding their heads right now. Yeah, and it was 10 pages of what was called Fun and Games, and one of them was a multi-choice quiz. called bamboozle and because normally so in the early days of teletext that's well I don't sure if that's early but in the early 80s right when you type in the page number of course you might have to wait a little while for that page to come around because in the in the signal every vertical blank is carrying an incrementing page number so if you're on page 100 and you have to and they cycle around so if you're on page 100 you type in page 600 it might currently be
我相信现在有几位听众在点头。是的，那是 10 页所谓的“娱乐与游戏”，其中一个是多项选择测验，叫 Bamboozle。因为通常情况下，在图文电视的早期，我不确定那是否算早期，但在 80 年代初，当你输入页码时，当然你可能需要等一会儿那个页面才会出现，因为在信号中，每个垂直消隐期都带着一个递增的页码，所以如果你在第 100 页，而它们是循环的，所以如果你在第 100 页，你输入第 600 页，它可能目前正在
broadcasting page 200, you just have to wait a few seconds for 600 to come around so the TV can display it. Later on, TV started to have a system called Fast Text, where they would cache for pages, and on the controller there were four, there were red, yellow, green and blue buttons corresponding to effectively hyperlinks within a page. The current page would say, you know, press red to go to such such page, green for another, blue, for another yellow, another. And the TV would know to pre-cash those pages so that it was likely they were already loaded by the time you pressed the color button. And so with that system, you have the building box to make a multi-choice quiz. And that was, you know, Bamboozle was the quiz that my sister
广播第 200 页，你只需要等几秒钟，600 页就会出现，电视就能显示它。后来，电视开始拥有一个叫 Fast Text 的系统，它们会缓存页面，在控制器上有四个按钮，红色、黄色、绿色和蓝色，对应于页面内的超链接。当前页面会说，你知道，按红色去某某页面，绿色去另一个，蓝色去另一个，黄色去另一个。电视会知道预先缓存这些页面，这样当你按下颜色按钮时，它们很可能已经加载好了。所以有了那个系统，你就有了制作多项选择测验的积木。那就是，你知道，Bamboozle 是我和我妹妹
and I used to play every day as teenagers. So who is, I mean, I've got a bunch of questions because this is all entirely novel to me. Well, I'll ask my second question first, because it's uh it's more relevant to what you were just saying who is uh like distributing that this is just some people on the internet that are broadcasting this to like all tvs and people that are switching to teletext like what's going on here it's not it's before the internet well you know not before arpanet but before right home internet um no it was the actual tv stations broadcasting this so every channel had their own branded version of teletext is the idea, right? The teletext is the protocol, if you like. Every channel has their branded
十几岁时每天都玩的测验。所以谁是，我是说，我有一堆问题，因为这对我来说完全是新奇的。好吧，我先问我的第二个问题，因为它与你刚才说的更相关，谁在分发这个？这只是互联网上的一些人在向所有电视广播这个，然后人们切换到图文电视吗？这到底是怎么回事？这不是互联网出现之前吗？好吧，你知道，不是阿帕网之前，而是家庭互联网之前，嗯，不，这是实际的电视频道在广播这个，所以每个频道都有自己品牌的图文电视版本，这就是这个想法，对吧？图文电视是一个协议，如果你愿意的话。每个频道都有他们品牌的
version of it. So the BBC's was called C-Fax, C-E-E-F-A-X. Link in the show notes. I'll go find some info on that. I believe ITV was Oracle and there was Channel 4 text as well. At that time, remember, we only had four TV channels broadcasting over the air. Wow. And a fifth one came along, I think, in the early 90s. But what percentage of folks that had TVs, and I assume all TVs had this capability, were switching to teletext mode. Was this a very common thing, or was this like kind of nerds that were only doing it? So, at least to begin with, not all TVs had this. And I think, you know, you had to pay extra for a TV with Teletext decoding circuitry.
版本。所以 BBC 的叫 C-Fax，C-E-E-F-A-X。节目说明里有链接。我会去查一些相关信息。我相信 ITV 是 Oracle，还有第 4 频道文本。当时，记住，我们只有四个通过无线广播的电视频道。哇。我想 90 年代初出现了第五个。但是拥有电视的人中，百分之多少（我假设所有电视都有这个功能）会切换到图文电视模式？这是一件很常见的事情，还是只有书呆子才这么做？所以，至少一开始，并非所有电视都有这个。而且我想，你知道，你必须为带有图文电视解码电路的电视支付额外费用。
But by the mid-1980s, it was pretty ubiquitous. And it wasn't only nerds because it was built into your appliance. Anyone could use it. You know, you wanted to find out. news at any time a day, you didn't have to wait for a news bulletin. You could just call up page 100 was the default, you know, and you start reading the news over teletext. You want to find out the weather forecast. You want to find out when your plane is departing and if it's on time. You want to find out traffic conditions, you know,
但到了 80 年代中期，它已经相当普遍了。而且不仅仅是书呆子，因为它内置在你的电器里。任何人都可以使用它。你知道，你想在一天中的任何时候了解新闻，你不必等待新闻简报。你可以直接调出第 100 页，这是默认的，你知道，然后你开始通过图文电视阅读新闻。你想了解天气预报。你想知道你的飞机什么时候起飞，是否准点。你想了解交通状况，你知道，
things like that. Anyone could use it. And importantly, subtitles also could be transmit with the teletext signal, and page 888 was always subtitles for the current program you are viewing. And the TV had a mode, as well as being able to display the regular signal or the teletext signal, it could superimpose the teletext signal on top of the regular signal, right? And that's how subtitles were done. So the teletext signal would just contain the subtitles, and the rest of the page would be, you know, transparent or not there. I'm not entirely sure exactly the system that was used. But basically, the TV could display the teletext signal on top of the regular analog broadcast signal.
诸如此类的事情。任何人都可以使用它。而且重要的是，字幕也可以通过图文电视信号传输，第 888 页总是你正在观看的节目的字幕。电视有一种模式，除了能够显示常规信号或图文电视信号外，它还可以将图文电视信号叠加在常规信号之上，对吧？这就是字幕的制作方式。所以图文电视信号只包含字幕，页面的其余部分是透明的或者不存在。我不完全确定所使用的确切系统。但基本上，电视可以将图文电视信号显示在常规模拟广播信号之上。
And that's how subtitles were done for many, many shows. Was this a global technology? Like, you were obviously in the UK. Was this in America as well? It was not in America. Different countries had different versions of it, I think, in Europe. The system I'm describing is, I think, only in the UK. Because it depends on your TV analog standard, right?
这就是许多许多节目的字幕制作方式。这是一种全球性的技术吗？你显然在英国。这在美国也有吗？美国没有。不同的国家有不同的版本，我想在欧洲。我描述的系统，我想只在英国。因为它取决于你的电视模拟标准，对吧？
The PAL standard, 50 Hertz, is one standard, and the way to fit telethics and that is, you know, do that one way. And you do it a different way for, I don't know, the French CCAM standard at the time, or if the US had had it, it would have been, it had to be in the NTSC standard. And I don't know.
PAL 标准，50 赫兹，是一种标准，适配图文电视的方法是，你知道，用那种方式。而对于当时的法国 SECAM 标准，或者如果美国有的话，它必须是 NTSC 标准，你得用不同的方式。我不知道。
if or what variants were around in other countries very interesting i had no idea about this and so the second question which was really my first question but out of order you mentioned mode seven uh my brain immediately mapped that to like you know today we have you know our whatever different six by nine 1080p like is mode seven like the earlier version of the different aspect ratios and like fidelity of uh your screen the number of well mode seven was a thing on the BBC Microcomputer. And it was just one of the, it's just a way of mapping memory to what comes out on the screen. Right.
其他国家有什么变体，非常有趣，我对此一无所知。所以第二个问题，也就是我真正想问的第一个问题，但顺序乱了，你提到了 Mode 7，我的大脑立刻把它映射到，你知道，今天我们有各种 16:9 1080p 之类的，Mode 7 是不同纵横比和屏幕保真度的早期版本吗？那个字符数……好吧，Mode 7 是 BBC Microcomputer 上的一个东西。它只是将内存映射到屏幕上显示的内容的一种方式。对。
So there were different modes. Some modes traded, for example, trade resolution for color resolution, right? So you could have a very high resolution mode, but not very many colors available in that mode. Or you could have a much lower resolution mode with more colors available. And some of that was also the case in early PC technology. You know, remember like 320 by 200. 320 by 200 cGA and vGA you know things like that yeah so that was you know back in the days of 8-bit and 16-bit computers that was that was the way you did it you had a fixed amount of video
所以有不同的模式。有些模式会权衡，例如，用分辨率换取颜色分辨率，对吧？所以你可以有一个非常高分辨率的模式，但在该模式下可用的颜色不多。或者你可以有一个分辨率低得多但可用颜色更多的模式。早期 PC 技术中也有这种情况。你知道，记得像 320x200。320x200 CGA 和 VGA 之类的，对吧，是的，所以那是，你知道，在 8 位和 16 位计算机时代，那就是你做这件事的方式，你拥有固定数量的视频
memory and you could you could have high-resolution images but but to fit in the same memory you needed to have fewer colors mode 7 was a textual mode if like i said was 40 characters by 20 five lines, so 1,000, one byte characters, and the character set, the code pages we might have called it, was, I think, custom. So there were control codes. I remember you could use a control code to print characters like double height, and you could do other things like make them flash, and you could make them all different colors. Interesting. A whole world of computing before my age
内存，你可以拥有高分辨率图像，但为了适应相同的内存，你需要更少的颜色。Mode 7 是一种文本模式，就像我说的，是 40 个字符乘 25 行，也就是 1000 个单字节字符，字符集，我们可能称之为代码页，我想是自定义的。所以有控制代码。我记得你可以使用控制代码来打印双倍高度的字符，你还可以做其他事情，比如让它们闪烁，你可以让它们变成各种不同的颜色。有趣。在我这个年龄之前的一个完整的计算世界。
there were lots of drawing or graphical block characters built into the character set you know so as well as the regular alpha numeric characters and punctuation you've got you know like and you've got a whole extra 120 plus characters
字符集中内置了许多绘图或图形块字符，你知道，所以除了常规的字母数字字符和标点符号外，你还有，你知道，你还有整整 120 多个额外的字符
you can use for whatever purpose and if you've got a custom character set you can just build in effectively drawing characters so you can make asky art-ish images and yeah that was a thing for I don't know how long did teletext last 20 years at least plus look at this we got to share this all right folks I mean we are we jump the gun we'll we'll say happy holidays in a bit but first things first I was thinking you know
你可以用于任何目的，如果你有一个自定义字符集，你可以直接构建有效的绘图字符，这样你就可以制作 ASCII 艺术风格的图像，是的，那是一个东西，我不知道，图文电视持续了多久，至少 20 年以上。看，我们得分享这个。好吧，各位，我是说，我们操之过急了，我们一会儿再说节日快乐，但首先，我在想，你知道
we talked about this a while ago uh I think it was definitely you that I can't remember if you had made a suggestion or you know but uh it was some kind of my big fat quiz of the year year end episode idea of you know in the style of some of the I can't remember if it was the my big fat quiz of the year some of the other because I played that clip once
我们前段时间谈过这个，我想肯定是你建议的，或者你知道，但这是一个类似于“我的年度大测验”的年终剧集想法，你知道，风格类似于……我记不清是“我的年度大测验”还是其他什么，因为我播放过那个片段一次
of I except I misattributed the comedian and I'm going to do it again but it's you know they're playing some unscrambled word which is like a mini game within the larger quiz and there's some guy are you thinking of eight out of test
除了我把喜剧演员搞错了，我又要再做一次，但你知道，他们正在玩某种解谜游戏，这是大型测验中的一个小游戏，有个家伙……你在想《8 Out of 10 Cats Does Countdown》吗？
8 out of 10 Cats Does Countdown? I think that's what it is, yeah. And so, like, I originally misattributed it to some other show and some other comedian, like Richard. It's fire, are they? Yeah, I think I misattributed it to him, but it was a different comedian. He's just, like, rapping the whole time, and then he's like, all right, I solved it, blood clot, which is clearly not a word. Oh, oh, yeah, okay. And then he says, I'll insert the clip again.
《8 Out of 10 Cats Does Countdown》？我想是那个，对。所以，我最初把它归因于其他节目和其他喜剧演员，比如 Richard。是 Fire，对吧？是的，我想我把它归因于他了，但那是另一位喜剧演员。他只是，你知道，一直在说唱，然后他说，好吧，我解决了，blood clot，这显然不是一个词。哦，哦，是的，好吧。然后他说，我会再次插入那个片段。
Hello and welcome to Countdown. Look, look, I'm on Countdown. Don't interrupt me. Tell Rachel your letters. Sam, Rach, um, a couple of B's, Q's, N, J. Just Pick a Letter. A bit serious on a show, isn't it? I'll tell you what, they'll have, um, put over your one up there.
你好，欢迎来到 Countdown。看，看，我在 Countdown 上。别打断我。告诉 Rachel 你的字母。Sam，Rach，嗯，几个 B，Q，N，J。随便选个字母。节目里有点严肃，不是吗？我告诉你，他们会，嗯，把你那个放上去。
All right. Fantastic. Okay, we've got, um... Help yourself, like a pick-a-mix. C, L. No? L. Grumpy, isn't you?
好吧。太棒了。好的，我们有，嗯……随便拿，像混合糖果一样。C，L。不？L。脾气暴躁，不是吗？
U. D, B. Fantastic. R. A and T. Okay. Stop the clock. Well, start the clock. Mr Gieser.
U。D，B。太棒了。R。A 和 T。好的。停止计时。好吧，开始计时。Mr Gieser。
Put the cares in the freezer. Ann Robinson. Ha! And Robinson. Have a breezer. Okay. Okay. We don't do that.
把 cares 放进冰箱。Ann Robinson。哈！And Robinson。喝杯啤酒。好的。好的。我们不那样做。
What can't you do that? No. Get a couple of cares, put him in the freezer. Shirley and Lisa. Gonna have a pizza. Do you know Rita? You don't know Rita? We're going to have a pizza.
为什么不能那样做？不。拿几个 cares，放进冰箱。Shirley 和 Lisa。要吃披萨。你认识 Rita 吗？你不认识 Rita？我们要吃披萨。
Okay. Fantastic, okay. Boom, I've got all the letters, Susie. Blood clark. Fantastic. It's all right, I win, eh? Um, that's not a word. That's a word. You're a bit moody, ain't ya?
好的。太棒了，好的。砰，我拿到了所有字母，Susie。Blood clark。太棒了。没关系，我赢了，呃？嗯，那不是一个词。那是一个词。你有点喜怒无常，不是吗？
Come on, give us a smile. It's not a word. Ha ha ha ha ha ha. And you are the weakest link. Goodbye. it's one of my favorite things because it's i can't i don't know any of these people's names right i've just seen this on youtube or instagram and the the lady who's like the moderator is very upset and she's telling the guy to be quiet and he's like you know lisa gonna have a pizza and yeah i remember i think that was a deliberate takeoff of countdown okay so it was maybe yeah the actual show of it
来吧，给我们一个微笑。那不是一个词。哈哈哈哈哈哈。你是最薄弱的一环。再见。这是我最喜欢的东西之一，因为我不知道这些人的名字，对吧？我只是在 YouTube 或 Instagram 上看到过这个，那个主持人女士非常生气，她告诉那个家伙安静点，而他就像，你知道，Lisa 要吃披萨，是的，我记得，我想那是对 Countdown 的故意模仿，好吧，所以也许是，是的，实际的节目
like uh anyways so but but that i think i'd mentioned that at one point anyways and there was this idea that maybe one of these year-end kind of holiday episodes, we'll get together a few people, and I'll be the moderator, and we'll do some countdown, you know, C++ programming software, whatever. Anyways, we had not the energy nor the time this year to do that, folks. Yeah, we've got like three days left before Christmas. Just for you to sort that out then, Colin? It did cross my mind. I was like, I could reach out to a few people. I'm sure Tony would be down, and, you know, I'm sure a few other folks. But anyways, in light of that, I am now about to share my screen.
像，呃，总之，但我认为我曾经提到过这一点，而且有一个想法是，也许这些年终节日剧集之一，我们会召集几个人，我来当主持人，我们会做一些 Countdown，你知道，C++ 编程软件，随便什么。总之，我们今年没有精力也没有时间做那个，各位。是的，离圣诞节还有三天。那你来解决这个问题吗，Colin？我确实想过。我想我可以联系几个人。我相信 Tony 会愿意的，而且，你知道，我相信还有其他人。但总之，鉴于此，我现在要分享我的屏幕。
We can do an entire screen, I believe. And look what we have here, folks. We have. There it is. Bamboozle. Bambor-Busler poses another 12 questions, answer using fast text at the bottom. One wrong, and you must try again. Can you answer all 12 in one attempt?
我相信我们可以共享整个屏幕。看看我们这里有什么，各位。我们有。就在那儿。Bamboozle。Bambor-Busler 又提出了 12 个问题，在底部使用 Fast Text 回答。错一个，你就必须重试。你能一次尝试回答所有 12 个问题吗？
I assume I can just use my most. So I was thinking while Ben was saying this, I wonder if this exists online. Sure enough, if you Google bamboozle, the second result, or I guess I googled BBC bamboozle quiz, is a digittextsim.com. And this is, yes, I mean, the listener can't see. But Ben is showing the sleeve of his Christmas sweater that inspired this conversation. And so we should, I mean, I'm probably not going to help much. Bamber Boozler says, good day, let's make it not a blue, but a musical Monday, with a dozen posers covering all styles and tastes ready.
我假设我可以直接用我的鼠标。所以当 Ben 说这话时，我在想，我想知道这是否在网上存在。果然，如果你谷歌 Bamboozle，第二个结果，或者我猜我谷歌的是 BBC Bamboozle quiz，是 digittextsim.com。是的，我是说，听众看不到。但 Ben 正在展示他圣诞毛衣的袖子，这激发了这次对话。所以我们应该，我是说，我可能帮不上什么忙。Bamber Boozler 说，美好的一天，让我们把它变成一个音乐星期一，而不是忧郁的星期一，有十二个涵盖所有风格和品味的难题准备好了。
And so I'm not a trivia person. I'll do my best to help, but this is probably going to be all on you, Ben. All right, I will try. Sam Rockwell is 52 this month, but in what film did he play a small role as a head thug with the line, regular or menthol? And I guess it's actually a, it's multiple choice. Red, teenage mutant, hero turtles, green, clownhouse, yellow,
所以我不是一个琐事达人。我会尽力帮忙，但这可能全靠你了，Ben。好吧，我会试试。Sam Rockwell 这个月 52 岁了，但在哪部电影中，他扮演了一个小角色，一个拿着台词“普通还是薄荷味？”的头号暴徒？我猜这实际上是一个，它是多项选择。红色，忍者神龟，绿色，Clownhouse，黄色，
the last exit to Brooklyn, and Cyan, Strictly Business. So the colors are like A, B, and C. Those aren't part of the titles, if you did not deduce that. Do you know, Ben? I don't know. Was there actually a film called Teenage Mutant Hero Turtles? That was what the Teenage Mutuals were called in the UK, but I don't think that's a film.
《最后退出布鲁克林》，青色，Strictly Business。所以颜色就像 A、B 和 C。如果你没推断出来，那些不是标题的一部分。你知道吗，Ben？我不知道。真的有一部叫《忍者神龟》的电影吗？那是忍者神龟在英国的叫法，但我不认为那是一部电影。
I was going to say, I thought that was like a fake answer because I've never heard of Hero Turtles. It's Ninja Turtles in North America. The only movie I've heard of in this list is Strictly Business. I mean, that's better, that's better than nothing. I mean, and Sam Rockwell is the guy that was more recently in season three of the White Lotus, which you may or may not have watched. I haven't watched. Also, he seems strictly business, when was that made?
我正想说，我以为那是一个假答案，因为我从未听说过 Hero Turtles。在北美是 Ninja Turtles。这个列表中我唯一听说过的电影是 Strictly Business。我是说，那比什么都没有要好。我是说，Sam Rockwell 是最近在《白莲花》第三季中出现的那个人，你可能看过也可能没看过。我没看过。而且他看起来 Strictly Business，那是什么时候拍的？
Early 90s? Maybe earlier? And he's only 52, which means at the time he would have been under 20 and he's playing a role as a head thug. So I don't know that it can be. strictly business. I'd be surprised. And is this quiz, I mean, is this a, like this is a current quiz, I assume, correct? It seems so. It's showing the current
90 年代初？也许更早？他才 52 岁，这意味着当时他不到 20 岁，他扮演了一个头号暴徒的角色。所以我不知道那能不能是 Strictly Business。我会很惊讶。而且这个测验，我是说，这是一个，这是一个当前的测验，我假设，对吗？看起来是这样。它显示了当前的
date. I would plump for last exit to Brooklyn. All right. That sounds. We're guessing yellow. It might be wrong, but that's my best guess. You've been bamboozled. Do you wish to play again? If so, press red. Okay. We got to start over? Yeah. But you get the same question, so you can sort of
日期。我会选《最后退出布鲁克林》。好吧。听起来不错。我们猜黄色。可能是错的，但这是我最好的猜测。你被 Bamboozled 了。你想再玩一次吗？如果是，按红色。好的。我们得从头开始？是的。但你会得到同样的问题，所以你可以某种程度上
make a way through it let's try your choice well i mean you said strictly business is a movie we don't know that the other one is do we know clownhouse is a movie so we're going to go we'll go with this we've been bamboozled again it has to be clown house then surely because teenage mutant hero turtles we've been it's apparently a movie now all right we're going to go through all 12 folks does it make the final cut we don't know super mario world is 30 this month which new character is introduced in in super Mario world today do they do they mean which new character was introduced I'm gonna say there's like there's like a missing information here what it's like what it's been interesting today because
找到方法，让我们试试你的选择。我是说，你说 Strictly Business 是一部电影，我们不知道另一个是不是，我们知道 Clownhouse 是一部电影吗？所以我们要选这个，我们又被 Bamboozled 了。那肯定是 Clownhouse，因为《忍者神龟》显然现在是一部电影了。好吧，我们要过完所有 12 个，各位。它能进入最终剪辑吗？我们不知道。超级马里奥世界这个月 30 岁了，超级马里奥世界中引入了哪个新角色？他们是说引入了哪个新角色吗？我要说这里缺少信息，今天为什么有趣，因为
sorry I haven't read the answers I was just confused red is Toadstool green is Bowser yellow is Yoshi and Cyan is warrior I mean we've got a better shot we what Mario what Mario oh he knows this for a fact no no no that's not the right answer I'm just correct correcting your pronunciation he says warrior i think we're starting over the answer is yoshi the answer is yoshi the answer is yoshi i think so all right there we go we're one for two we're not going to count me clicking it's wario i said wario you said waria i think or waria i apologize folks i shima and i have been playing a lot of the we uh mario cart so i you know i should know a little bit more but here we go question three this is up
抱歉，我没读答案，我只是困惑。红色是 Toadstool，绿色是 Bowser，黄色是 Yoshi，青色是 Wario。我是说，我们有更好的机会，我们……什么马里奥，什么马里奥？哦，他确定知道这个。不，不，那不是正确答案，我只是在纠正你的发音。他说 Wario，我想我们要从头开始了。答案是 Yoshi，答案是 Yoshi，答案是 Yoshi，我想是这样。好吧，我们二中一了。我们不会算我点击的次数。是 Wario，我说 Wario，你说 Waria，我想，或者 Waria，我很抱歉，各位。我和 Shima 一直在玩很多马里奥赛车，所以我应该多知道一点，但我们开始吧，第三题，这是关于
Barale, what do the initials how for the Hal 9,000 computer mean in the film 2001, a space odyssey? Instead of doing red, green, yellow, and cyan, we're going to do A, B, C, and D, just to make it a little bit easier for the listener. A,
Barale，在电影《2001 太空漫游》中，Hal 9000 计算机的首字母缩写 Hal 代表什么？我们不选红、绿、黄、青，我们选 A、B、C 和 D，让听众更容易一点。A，
hateful, artificial life form. B, heuristically programmed algorithmic computer. C, hardware, AI language, and D, highly advanced language. I actually don't know this one. I have a guess, but my guess is
Hateful Artificial Life form（可恶的人工生命形式）。B，Heuristically programmed Algorithmic computer（启发式编程算法计算机）。C，Hardware AI language，D，Highly advanced language。我其实不知道这个。我有一个猜测，但我的猜测是
be heuristically programmed algorithmic computer and I'm wondering if it's a backronym because Hal is you may or may not have remarked on this each letter of Hal is one letter back from IBM I was going to say I know that there's some
B，启发式编程算法计算机，我在想它是不是一个反向首字母缩写，因为 Hal，你可能评论过，也可能没评论过，Hal 的每个字母都是 IBM 的前一个字母。我正想说，我知道有某种
other backronym kind of thing I wonder if that's how they but yeah I wouldn't have been able to tell you that off the top of my head but as soon as you said one or whatever I was like it's going to be like the APLBQN thing so let's guess my guess is also be a heuristically programmed algorithmic computer we are correct that I think is what three three for four three four I don't know how many times they don't
其他反向首字母缩写之类的东西，我想知道那是不是他们……但是的，我无法脱口而出告诉你。但你一说 1 或其他什么，我就想它会像 APLBQN 那样。所以让我们猜，我的猜测也是 B，启发式编程算法计算机。我们是对的，我想那是三中三，四中三，我不知道他们多少次
give us the score what's going on bamboos will give us a score question whatever we're on we'll say four which board game is played with teams of players trying to identify specific words from their teammates drawings all right I know this one even without looking at it A scatigories B charades. C. Pictionary or D. Sketchy. It is let Ben answer. It's pictionary. Yes. I'm assuming. Yes. That's what you're thinking. Yes, that's what I indeed was thinking. All right. I know this one as well, folks. Question five. We think we don't actually know what is the chemical symbol for silver. A, A, A, G, B, A-A-U, C-A-L, or D-P-B. You know this one, I assume.
给我们分数，怎么回事？Bamboozle 给我们一个分数。问题，无论我们在哪，我们说是四。哪种棋盘游戏是团队玩家试图从队友的画作中识别特定单词？好吧，即使不看我也知道这个。A，Scatigories。B，Charades。C，Pictionary。D，Sketchy。让 Ben 回答。是 Pictionary。是的。我假设。是的。这就是你在想的。是的，我确实在想那个。好吧，我也知道这个，各位。第五题。我们认为我们不知道银的化学符号是什么。A，AG，B，AU，C，AL，或者 D，PB。你知道这个，我假设。
course. Yeah. Any crossword, aficionado knows silver and gold at least. AG, yeah. Oh, well, I mean, those aren't the definitions. In the official, the OPSD, the official player's Scrabble Dictionary,
当然。是的。任何填字游戏爱好者至少知道银和金。AG，是的。哦，我是说，那些不是定义。在官方的 OPSD，官方玩家拼字词典中，
which is a subset of the NWL, the North American word list, AG is actually short for agriculture. And AL is an Arabian shrub. What is a, so I think P.B. lead, right? And what is A. L is aluminum? Gold and aluminum, yeah. Aluminium. Aluminum, if you like. I just saw an Instagram real about the pronunciation of that the other day. But anyways, we're going to go with AG. It is correct. That's, uh, ooh, I know this one as well. That's maybe we
它是 NWL（北美词汇表）的一个子集，AG 实际上是农业的缩写。AL 是一种阿拉伯灌木。什么是 A，所以我认为 PB 是铅，对吧？AL 是铝？金和铝，是的。Aluminium。如果你喜欢的话，铝。我前几天刚在 Instagram 上看到关于那个发音的视频。但总之，我们要选 AG。它是正确的。那是，呃，哦，我也知道这个。那也许我们
started off with a hard one, but these ones are getting a little bit easier. Sometimes it works out that way. So question six, in regards to beer, what does IPA stand for? A, independently pumped ale, B, independently produced ale, C, Indian pale ale, or D, Indian-produced ale. I imagine you know the answer to this one as well. Yeah. It is C, Indian pale ale. My favorite type of beer, folks. Uh-oh.
开始时选了一个难的，但这些变得容易了一些。有时就是这样。所以第六题，关于啤酒，IPA 代表什么？A，Independently Pumped Ale，B，Independently Produced Ale，C，Indian Pale Ale，或者 D，Indian-Produced Ale。我想你也知道这个答案。是的。是 C，Indian Pale Ale。我最喜欢的啤酒类型，各位。呃哦。
All right, I definitely don't know this one. So we're calling it, whatever. Question seven, maybe eight. We've lost track. What type of farm? We'll come back through. Yeah, I'll fix it in post. I definitely won't fix it in post, but it's, what type.
好吧，我肯定不知道这个。所以我们叫它，随便吧。第七题，也许第八题。我们记不清了。什么类型的农场
of farm did Taylor Swift grow up on? A, ranch, B, flower farm, C, micro farm, or D, Christmas tree farm? I don't even know what a micro farm is. I was saying, I'm ruling out micro farm just because that sounds fake. Flower farm seems unlikely in the US. I agree. Is she, is she American or Canadian? She's a well, I don't know what you know. I don't know what percentage of our listeners are Taylor Swift fans. So we might lose a couple listeners here. I'm almost positive she's American. Actually, no, she has to be because we would know.
Taylor Swift 是在什么农场长大的？A，牧场，B，花卉农场，C，微型农场，或者 D，圣诞树农场？我甚至不知道什么是微型农场。我正想说，我排除了微型农场，因为那听起来很假。花卉农场在美国似乎不太可能。我同意。她是，她是美国人还是加拿大人？她是一个……好吧，我不知道你知道什么。我不知道我们的听众中有多少是 Taylor Swift 的粉丝。所以我们可能会失去几个听众。我几乎肯定她是美国人。其实不，她一定是，因为我们会知道。
Like, I know that Justin Bieber is Canadian because it's a huge deal. So the fact that I don't know means that she's American. Well, I leave it. It's your guess. Red and cyan are both. Oh, sorry, A and D are both plausible. Yeah, I think it's either A or D. I mean, I'm kind of leaning towards D because
就像，我知道 Justin Bieber 是加拿大人，因为那是一件大事。所以我不确定这一事实意味着她是美国人。好吧，我留着它。这是你的猜测。红色和青色都是。哦，抱歉，A 和 D 都是合理的。是的，我认为是 A 或 D。我是说，我有点倾向于 D，因为
Because it's more interesting. Yeah, and also too, like, if she grew up on a ranch, why would you make a question of, like, the types of farms, right? Yeah. Ah, good, good thought. Like, it just, like, I wouldn't ever think, oh, she grew up on a ranch. Let's make a question about the type of farm she lived on. It's, like, what, ranch is, like, the only type of farm, really.
因为它更有趣。而且，如果她在牧场长大，你为什么要出一个关于农场类型的问题，对吧？是的。啊，好想法。就像，我永远不会想，哦，她在牧场长大。让我们出一个关于她居住的农场类型的问题。这就像，牧场是唯一真正的农场类型。
Yeah. But if it's Christmas tree farm, it's like, oh, we can come up with a few others. All right. All right. So, let's guess, D. Oh, we got it right. All right, yes. We didn't, we didn't actually know.
是的。但如果是圣诞树农场，就像，哦，我们可以想出其他几个。好吧。好吧。所以，让我们猜 D。哦，我们猜对了。好吧，是的。我们其实不知道。
I know that one though. I was just educated guess. Okay, this one I know. Eight or nine? I definitely don't. Who was Henry the Eighths? That's V with three eyes for those that are wondering. Who was Henry the Eighth's last wife?
不过我知道那个。我只是受过教育的猜测。好的，这个我知道。八还是九？我肯定不知道。谁是亨利八世的？对于那些想知道的人，那是 V 后面跟着三个 I。谁是亨利八世的最后一任妻子？
A. Catherine Howard, B. Catherine Parr C. Anne of Cleves and D. Jane Seymour. I have not a clue. The answer is B. Catherine Parr. Catherine Howard, I think, was number five. Five, out of Cleese number four, Jane C, one number three, Catherine Parr, number six. Damn, look at that folks.
A，Catherine Howard，B，Catherine Parr，C，Anne of Cleves，D，Jane Seymour。我一点头绪都没有。答案是 B。Catherine Parr。Catherine Howard，我想是第五个。第五个，Anne of Cleves 是第四个，Jane Seymour 是第三个，Catherine Parr 是第六个。该死，看看那个，各位。
Do they teach you that in school, or you just are avid reader of the history of... They teach you, I don't know if they teach you that in school. You kind of get that through osmosis. Wow. Also, you're a cryptic crossword guy, so I will say I did do a cryptic crossword while I was in Australia. Oh, yeah? I did get a little bit, there was a speaker at the conference. that taught me a trick of like,
这是学校教你的，还是你只是个历史狂热读者……他们教过，我不确定学校是否教过这个。你大概是通过耳濡目染学到的。哇。而且，你还是个填字游戏高手，所以我得说，我在澳大利亚时确实玩过填字游戏。哦，是吗？我确实学到了一点，会议上有一位演讲者教了我一个技巧，就是
you need to draw a line down the clue that kind of separates the words. Yeah, which I don't know, maybe you had told me, but it didn't, if you had said something like that, like I knew there's two parts to the clue, but I had never visually tried to find a dividing line
你需要沿着线索画一条线，把词语分开。是的，我不知道，也许你告诉过我，但如果当时你说了类似的话，虽然我知道线索有两部分，但我从未尝试过在视觉上找到一条分割线
that like, uh, severs, you know, the, uh, like definition and the word play. Exactly. And when I started doing that,
把定义和文字游戏分开。没错。当我开始这样做的时候，
sometimes you can just like slice the clue, look at one half and then, you know, hope that the other half match. it, especially if you have a couple letters. Anyways, not the elegant way to solve it. But anyways, Catherine Parr, B, and we are, I think so that's, I think it's only one wrong at this point out of, we'll say nine.
有时你可以直接切开线索，看一半，然后希望另一半能对上，特别是如果你已经有几个字母了。总之，这不是解决它的优雅方式。但无论如何，凯瑟琳·帕尔，B，我们是，我想目前为止我们只错了一个，我们说是九个。
So we'll call this number 10. We'll find out in a couple questions. What is the lifespan of a dragonfly? A, 12 hours, B, eight hours, C, 24 hours, and D, 48 hours. Are you kidding me? All dragonflies live two days or less? Well, I'm wondering about this clue. is this meaning to say mayfly or a dragonfly is really that short-lived as well because
所以我们称之为第10题。我们几道题后就会知道。蜻蜓的寿命是多少？A，12小时，B，8小时，C，24小时，D，48小时。你在开玩笑吗？所有蜻蜓的寿命都只有两天或更短？嗯，我在想这个线索，这是指蜉蝣吗？还是蜻蜓的寿命真的也这么短，因为
mayflies are from the ephemera genus you know we just cognate with ephemeral I was going to say is ephemera ephemera is the same as ephemeral that's uh and mayflies are often confused with dragonflies I'm not sure that dragonflies really live this short of a time but anyway we'll go with what we have I'm going to say 48 hours so I don't think it's shorter than that we've bamboot we were doing so well start again we know we know we know the answers though so and this time we'll count all right so we were all right this is question nine so we're question nine i was only one question off of 12 you're going to go with 12 now uh no question question nine of 12 um let's go for 24 hours 24 hey there we go so we're seven for nine at this point
蜉蝣属于蜉蝣属，你知道的，这和“短暂的”是同源词。我正想说，蜉蝣和短暂的是同一个词，那是……而且蜉蝣经常被误认为是蜻蜓。我不确定蜻蜓的寿命真的有这么短，但无论如何，我们先按现有的选。我要选48小时，我不认为它比这更短。我们之前做得很好，重新开始吧。我们知道答案，这次我们要数一下。好的，所以我们是对的，这是第九题，所以我们是第九题，我离12题只差一题。你现在要选12吗？呃，不，第九题，共12题。嗯，我们选24小时吧。24，好了，我们现在是九题对了七题。
next question so question number 10 third last question sean of the dead hot fuzz and which other film make up the three flavors cornetto trilogy. Do you know this one? I didn't, well, not off the top of my head, but maybe we can, do you know this one?
下一题，第10题，倒数第三题。《僵尸肖恩》、《热血警探》和哪部电影构成了“血与冰淇淋三部曲”？你知道这个吗？我不知道，嗯，不是脱口而出，但也许我们可以……你知道这个吗？
I do. Okay, perfect. A, run, fat boy run. B, the world's end. C, Paul, or D. Big Nothing. Honestly, like, these are films. I haven't heard of Run,
我知道。好的，完美。A，《肥仔快跑》，B，《世界尽头》，C，《保罗》，D，《大麻烦》。老实说，这些电影我都没听说过《肥仔快跑》，
fat boy run. That's a song to me. Or, I think I Actually, the song is run, but there's a line in it that says that. Anyways, so that doesn't scream movie to me. The World's End, I'm pretty sure, is a comedy with, I don't know, Leonardo DiCaprio and Jonah Hill. Is that the climate change one? I don't know.
对我来说那是首歌。或者，我想我……其实那首歌叫《Run》，但里面有一句歌词是那样。总之，这听起来不像电影名。《世界尽头》，我相当确定是一部喜剧，有……我不知道，莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥和乔纳·希尔主演。那是关于气候变化的那部吗？我不知道。
There's some movie recently. No, you're thinking of don't look up, I think. That's what I'm thinking of. The World's End is indeed a comedy with Simon Pegg, who also stars in Shonda the Dead and Hot Fuss. Yeah, yeah. So I was going to say, for the wrong reasons, I was going to guess that the world's end sounds like a movie to me. Paul does not. Big nothing does not. So is it B, the world's end? All right. So I would have guessed correctly, but not because I had heard of the movie. Or maybe I had, but was confusing it. So that's eight for 10. Two questions left. Oh, I mean, this one's easy. This might be the easiest of all in terms of how many people would know it. Which famous boxer could, quote, float like a butterfly and quote, sting like a bee. choices are. A, Muhammad Ali, B, Mike Tyson, C. Frank Bruno, or D. Evanderholi Field. I'm pretty sure it's A, correct? Yeah. I did have to think for a sec, because Mike Tyson is also very famous, but it definitely is not him. And do you know? Definitely, Ali. Do I know also his actual name?
最近有部电影。不，我想你想到的是《不要抬头》。我想到的是那个。《世界尽头》确实是一部由西蒙·佩吉主演的喜剧，他也主演了《僵尸肖恩》和《热血警探》。是的，是的。所以我本来想说，出于错误的原因，我猜《世界尽头》听起来像部电影。《保罗》不像。《大麻烦》也不像。所以是B，《世界尽头》吗？好的。所以我本来会猜对，但不是因为我听说过这部电影。或者也许我听说过，但记混了。所以是10题对了8题。还剩两题。哦，我是说，这题很简单。就多少人知道而言，这可能是最简单的一题。哪位著名拳击手可以“像蝴蝶一样飞舞，像蜜蜂一样蜇人”？选项是：A，穆罕默德·阿里，B，迈克·泰森，C，弗兰克·布鲁诺，D，伊万德·霍利菲尔德。我相当确定是A，对吧？是的。我确实想了一秒钟，因为迈克·泰森也非常出名，但肯定不是他。你知道吗？肯定是阿里。我也知道他的原名吗？
Cassius Clay? Cassius Clay? His original name? Or yeah, yeah, original name. I'm not sure if it was legally changed. It was pseudonym or whatever. ever happened. Anyway, so that is the... Here we go. There we go. What a great question to end on, folks. Question number 12,
卡修斯·克莱？卡修斯·克莱？他原来的名字？或者，是的，是的，原来的名字。我不确定他是否在法律上改了名。那是化名还是别的什么。无论如何，这就是……好了。好了。真是个完美的结尾题，各位。第12题，
what is the nickname of the character played by Morgan Freeman in one of the best movies of all time, folks? Shawshank Redemption. It's actually kind of funny because... It's a strep test. We're saying ABCD, but actually, I'll read it out this time. Red blue, green, green, yellow, brown, or cyan red.
摩根·弗里曼在史上最伟大的电影之一中饰演的角色的绰号是什么，各位？《肖申克救赎》。这其实挺有趣的，因为……这是个链式测试。我们说ABCD，但这次我会读出来。红、蓝、绿、绿、黄、棕，或者青红。
other words, A, blue, B, green, C, brown, or D, red. And I know Ben knows the answer to this question. It is definitely red. Yep. Which, well done. How many did you get right the first time? Check your rating below. We got, I believe it was 10 for 12.
换句话说，A，蓝，B，绿，C，棕，或者D，红。我知道本知道这道题的答案。肯定是红。是的。做得好。你第一次答对了多少？查看下方的评分。我们，我相信是12题对了10题。
And it says that we are almost great performance is 10 to 11. Zero to 2. Were you really trying? Because it's on the internet these days, you can't really change. cheat in the way that my sister and I used to sometimes cheat because, and it's a risky strategy. Now, of course, when the tele-tick signal is cycling around, as it were, your TV is busy cashing the pages for the red, blue, yellow, and green options, which means that there's a short time before it's cached any of them, and you can, if you press red and there's no page
上面说我们表现几乎很棒，10到11分。0到2分。你真的尽力了吗？因为现在互联网上，你不能像我和我妹妹以前那样作弊，因为那是一种冒险的策略。当然，当图文电视信号循环时，你的电视正忙着缓存红、蓝、黄、绿选项的页面，这意味着在它缓存任何页面之前有一小段时间，你可以，如果你按了红色，而没有页面
cache, then nothing happens until that page comes around. So you can try multiple answers in one go, as it were. And that's what you would do? That's what we would sometimes do. It didn't always work very well because you're literally racing the TV signal. But if there was a question that we had no idea, we'd sometimes try and exploit the nature of the signal to try and eliminate answers more quickly. You can't do that on the internet. where every click just takes you straight away. Right, obviously, this website that cannot be beaten in terms of time. Anyways, that was fun.
缓存，那么在页面出现之前什么都不会发生。所以你可以一次尝试多个答案。这就是你会做的？这就是我们有时会做的。它并不总是很有效，因为你实际上是在和电视信号赛跑。但如果有一道题我们完全不知道，我们有时会尝试利用信号的特性来更快地排除答案。你在互联网上做不到这一点，因为每次点击都会直接带你过去。对，显然，这个网站在时间上是无法被击败的。总之，这很有趣。
A little quiz, you know, stay tuned until 2026 year end. Will Connor have the time and energy to put together a countdown-style C++ programming language quiz? Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode as well as a link to a get-up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. I am the anti-brace. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
一个小测验，你知道，敬请关注到2026年底。康纳会有时间和精力整理出一个倒计时风格的C++编程语言测验吗？请务必查看这些节目说明，无论是在你的播客应用中还是在ADSPthepodcast.com上，获取我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个GitHub讨论链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。我是反括号。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。